une production du studio sfr bienvenue
au centre le podcast on parle ce qu'on
veut nous a évité à chaque fois je
m'appelle ph cantagoy dôme plantes ix
cette semaine on a reçu boucar diouf un
humain extraordinaire un gars brillant
comme j'ai rarement vu cadiou vous le
connaissez les humoristes homme de radio
télévision mais aussi scientifique en
fait lui le il a fait ses études au
sénégal en afrique avant de venir faire
son doctorat ici au québec tu arrives à
rimouski le ya vécu l'hiver parties
signent de vraiment de gros changements
béton puis façon doctorat en biologie
marine puis en océanographie puis en
fait c'est vraiment beaucoup de science
qu'on a parlé aujourd'hui dans le
podcast d'évolution des biologies
d'environnement c'était passionnant in
the partager son savoir le vraiment j'ai
capoté
j'ai capoté vous allez capote
vous allez entendre c'est vraiment nos
podcasts pauvres et moi c'est dans mon
top 3 vous écouter sur youtube à l'ado
spotify les seigneuries thing laissez
nous un commentaire ça fait son bout de
chemin on commence à avoir une grosse
communauté autour de nous c'est vraiment
le fun de voir tout ce qu'on va
commencer à faire sur notre page pétrone
des podcasts on essaie on en promet un à
chaque deux semaines puis ça va être on
va rencontrer des gens qui sont un petit
peu moins connus mais qui ont des
parcours super intéressant donc si vous
êtes avides de podcasts vous voulez nous
en venons de parler encore plus
dirigez vous sur notre page piquionne
dans la description de la vidéo du
podcast que vous écoutez ici il va voir
nos pages pétulant aller voir ce
abonnez-vous c'est aussi la meilleure
façon de supporter contenus exclusifs
et en plus nous on a une proximité
vraiment les membres pétrone justement
on était à ma taille même avec un homme
pétri en qui veut nous aider au studio
on dit pas qu'on va aider tout le monde
qu'on va éviter tout le monde au studio
c'est magique vous payez puis vous venez
nous aider grèce sinon restez à l'affût
des podcasts du studio sfg du temps on
discute
ouais le temps de juger barricades à
vous aussi vous d'avoir d'autres enfants
ici au studio vous savez déjà mais en
plus de nos podcasts ont offert d'autres
podcast elle a d'autres qui s'en
viennent bientôt ça va vraiment devenir
un espèce de d'endroits de des créations
aux crédits contenus
je pense qu'il ya d'autres que moi ça
m'excite le ceat microsoft
c'est un mec ce d'autant que la
conversation cardio que vous avez écouté
à l'instinct donc bon pas de casque
bonne écoute
[Musique]
boukar nous a fait plaisir c'était
vraiment le fun quand on me dit que j'ai
accepté l'invitation
les au compteur soit ici dans le studio
moi j'étais j'étais invité pour parler
d'insectes ouais et sa mère à la nature
selon bucarest est une des choses que
j'ai eu le plus de fans affronter avec
toutes les espèces de frénésie
d'occupation de tous les quatre moins
vite et j'étais vraiment content
d'accepter puis j'étais excité à l'idée
de venir te parler parce que parce que
depuis tout petit une fait rire puis je
trouve je trouve intéressant et
pertinent puis c'était vraiment une
belle invitation tout mais finalement
ils policier fait manquer les way c'est
parce que justement c'est parce que je
connaissais hopper est en quelqu'un qui
l'écoutaient l'émission avec moyenne
chez nous à la maison et je connaissais
aussi son pedigree son passé donc je le
regarde et puis ce qui m'intrigue et
parce que je me disais comment ce type
qui était à laval dans un domaine quand
même assez pointue et rentrer là dedans
et l'intrigué il ya quelque chose qui
m'intrigue et chez lui je voulais le
vérifier ces problèmes et éviter un
personnage me retrouve un personnage
mystérieux ph quand même pas voilà un
vrai c'est mystérieux moi j'ai une
piscine c'est ainsi puis le ph tu vas
voir c'est quelque chose que j'avais
j'avais mais le fait que c'était de ces
tests est devant public
oui est ce que tu fais encore pour cette
année
et pourquoi pas le choix de faire
d'avoirs publics qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce
qui fait que
qu'est ce qui est un plus ajouté de
faire l'émission devant public mais je
pense que c'est juste pour avoir les
invités et un feeling sur place de ce
qu'ils disent c'est pas la même chose
car quand tu le fais en l'absence de
public il ya des gens qui le fait
d'avoir quelqu'un autour qui réagit à ce
qu'il dit vers rendent meilleure c'est
pas et puis donc c'est de l'éducation
populaire aussi quand j'ai créé cette
émission
avec mon ami martin girard ce qu'on
voulait faire c'est de l'éducation
populaire donc quand tu donnes en cours
j invite les gens à faire de la
vulgarisation mais devant une classe une
petite classe constituée par le public
et la classe par extension les gens qui
nous écoutent à la maison donc c'est ça
puis on voit la différence c'est une
énergie dudit public l'énergie ont le
sens et on était à québec qui a la
semaine passée puis on faisait une
émission sur l'ours polaire l'ours
polaire est là les changements
climatiques
les réfugiés climatiques est ce qui vous
fait encore une section avec avec un
sujet connexe insouciance au début oui
après ça c'était quoi la connexion dans
cete sciences sociales et sciences pures
west s'est classée biens saisis donc
nous ont mal de l'ours polaire avec
quelqu'un qui fait de la biologie et on
parle des réfugiés climatiques avec une
professeur de l'université du québec à
chicoutimi donc qu'on l'impact de la
fonte des glaces sur les ours et qu'est
ce qu'ils vivent maintenant son vaincre
et avant il attrapait beaucoup de
phoques maintenant et en os - c'est
terrifiant les images d'ours polaires en
ce moment et plusieurs documentaires
animaliers sur yon qui s'appelle à la
planète qui est sorti sur netflix
dernière mais qui se fait un peu regardé
changement climatique à la positive au
sens où ils disent voici qu est ce qu on
pourrait sauver
oui maintenant on arrête oui route et
puis les images d'ours polaires de
l'arctique c'est horrifiant des
horribles théorie parce que la banque
ait disparu tous ces espèces sont des
espèces qui dépend de la banquise d'ours
polaires c'est un animal marin on
l'oubli là mais il s'appelle aussi ce
maritimus c'est pas pour rien ce parce
qu'on est capable de nager 10 heures non
stop et plus un animal marin que
terrestres mais son succès à vie dépend
beaucoup de la banquise pour la chasse
fo qui marche sa banquise semaine les
foi parce qu'ils chassent pas dans l'eau
c'est très rare mais maintenant quand la
banque qui le font les autres par
beaucoup plus de temps à nager y nage
chez des phoques c'est démonter que le
nombre de phoques capturé par un ours a
diminué beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et
derniers temps donc son maigre
ils s'en vont vers le sud ils essayent
d'entrer dans les maisons et ils
essaient de s'adapter aussi de la façon
qui m'a aidé et d'oiseaux et mais ça ça
coûte cher en énergie à les capturer des
petits oiseaux parce que ça donne
pendant les ca proches des humains parce
que c'est ça l'ours polaire maintenance
au croiser avec les grizzlies parce que
c'est presque la même espèce sans
croisement des croisements joliment une
zone où l'église lice l'ours polaire se
croisent avec l'église lissaden
d'épicerie les financières pessah
desgrolard pour l'ars info et puis c'est
plus bourré temps mais on l'a remarqué
mme emna que c'est facile de s'adapter
aux changements climatiques en modifiant
vraiment leur a été démontré que même
maintenant l'attend les épaulards qui
collaborent avec les baleines à bosse
pour chasser ça ouais il sait tout ça
c'est à cause de la raréfaction de la
ressource dans la réflexion de la
ressource mais l'ours est vraiment car
c'est pour ça moi quand je vois des gens
qui ont beaucoup d'argent qui payent des
dizaines de milliers de dollars pour les
justes allait tuer un ours spécial la
chasse aux trophées on en voit aussi ses
et chasseurs des lions les chasseurs cdd
gauche biais comme ceux qui s'est
purement pour le plaisir de spatialiser
nancy se tient la grèce quelque chose
qui m'a amené juste pour accrocher la
tête dans ton salon pour dire à tes amis
qui viennent te voir dans ton chat les
rues d'alger des grosses couilles
parce que c'est ça vraiment prouver que
tu as des grosses couilles il a fait le
conflit faisait les à l'époque des
romains dans la vase et avec ton oui oui
avec ton couteau de chasse
ouais on lâche les lions dans l'arène
vont passer quelque chose
un argument que moi je reçois beaucoup
tirent défendant la cause du véganisme
je reçois l'argument des chasseurs
qu'ils disent ou un métier à la chasse
et à ta bouffe tcc mars et masculin
bleuté avoir un fusil qui a changé une
cache pendant deux jours admet de la
paix
deux femelles sur toi puis a tiré à 200
mètres de l'animal 5 lui de voix il rien
de rien le masculin d'héroïque dans six
attaques ne prend un couteau puis essaie
d'aller sur narnia avec un couteau mais
on va se refermer sur ses lauriers je
pense que c'est quelque chose quand
c'est bien réglementé moi je n'ai
absolument rien ça fout que soit
réglementé mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
parce que tu as tu es un ours quota des
grosses couilles la moins fort mais non
mais non si tu veux faire ça fait là
qu'on faisait les massaï à l'époque
l'asie la 4e manche tout ouïe l'ours qui
couvre toi de sa poule
ben oui pour rien gaspiller les inuits
les naskapis c'est ça qui faisait là les
unités naskapis qu'a essuyé un animal
c'était pour célébrer la vie de l'animal
jusqu'à la fin je vais manger la chair
la grèce qui vont l'utiliser combustible
les eaux ils vont utiliser les eaux ils
vont fabriquer des cordages avec les
tendons ils vont fabriquer des cas
qu'avec la peau ou alors c est même la
peau comme tu disais il mettait sur e et
10 e temps que tu portes la peau ses
sept premières nations ben tu vas garder
un contact avec l'animal gratuit et ça
c'est pour moi ça s'appelle célébrer le
caractère sacré de la vie c'est pas
juste dire hey je les tire et après
avoir avalé 24 surtout qu'ils tuaient
par nécessité c'est complètement une
question de survie et les inouïes dans
nos confères l'agriculture c'est la
seule manière de les nourrir ça va être
par la chasse dont un lot a pas le choix
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup d'animaux qui
sont morts pas par nécessité mais par
lux ou par habitude ou partir mais moi
c'est le luxe voilà moi la chasse aux
trophées c'est avec ça c'est ça c'est
cela le trophée moi aussi je suis je
suis assez nuancée par rapport à mes
propos pour la chasse je trouve que
trouve que les chasseurs souvent ont
beaucoup plus en commun avec les vegan
que les gens qui achètent la viande à
l'épicerie des industriels et a causé la
conscience environnementale a conscience
du respect de la vie de l'animal
oui mais effectivement la chasse aux
trophées qui a directement aucun qu'une
utilité qu'une utilité autre que
je mens comme tu disais faudra encore
deux qui pisse le plus loin et puis oui
on s'entend que c'est absolument
horrible ça c'est l'émoi chez les deux
en tout cas là qui me dérange parce que
moi j'ai plein d'amis qui sont des
chasseurs de l'univers de la mort j puis
c'est des gens qui respectent le
caractère sacré de la vie ici il
respecte ayons des règlements qui ces
règlements sont là c'est ça qu'on prenne
un pis aller façon de le faire at il le
respecte mais quand tu t'en vas la
tuture en gros carnivores aujourd'hui la
comme le lion cécile à l'époque qui
avait déchaîné des passions et tue le
tue mais c'est juste pour prouver que
j'étais capable de tuer un gros
carnivores ou tu pour enlever la corne
c'est comme les rhinocéros
parce que tu es convaincu que la corne
de rhinocéros va augmenter tes
performances sexuelles
je sais pas quoi les biologistes disant
jugez vous les angles d'augmenter les
performances sexuelles oui exactement
parce que la la comme d'une hausse et là
c'est juste de la kératine si la
kératine tire tout ça dans les angles
dans les poêles dans les plumes des
oiseaux dans les sabots dans les
carapaces de tortues ça fait que si vous
économisez la rouge soit les ongles
si tu en as pas assez des vaches c'est
quelqu'un qui fait de la manucure depuis
2008 à faire une réserve donc tu réduis
sans un pote ça fait là même la peau de
grille on a fait nos angles basse et
c'est ça que ça devrait même et c'est
vraiment passionnant le
justement toit d'un point de vue
personnel tu doit adorer
à chaque émission en apprendre davantage
sur quelque chose tu es un autre aspect
de la nature peu après sur un autre
aspect de la vie humaine
ah oui tout c'est de la formation
continue non mais moi je le dis souvent
si c'est une très bonne question moi je
le dis souvent je dis aux gens moi j'ai
fait un doctorat en biologie à
l'université du québec à rimouski et en
faisant cette émission j'ai appelé deux
fois plus que pendant tout mon cursus
scolaire parce que j'ai abordé plein de
sujets que je n'ai jamais jamais abordé
quand est venu on va l'aider éphémère
avec jean-pierre bourassa qui était
volume experts des effets oui voilà
et moi je rencontre le le monde est
rempli de gens qu'on ne voit pas et qui
font des choses extraordinaires et qui
mérite qu'on commette la lumière sur eux
parce que et moi c'est ça surtout c'est
de devoir d'aller chercher des
passionnés et kitana prenable comme tu
dis tous les jours tous les jours moi je
considère que j'ai une vision pas mal un
peu plus multidirectionnel aujourd'hui
de la cie des sciences de la nature que
quand j'ai fini mes études ou quand j'ai
enseigné la biologie la physiologie
humaine ou la biochimie c'est parce que
j'apprends tous les jours je soutiens
une certitude ce set
dans cette vie c'est qu'on ne connaît
bien même si on pense savoir quelque
chose reconnaît dans l'infini des
connaissances qui a à voir on connaît
seulement même la personne la plus
éduquée au monde ne connaît qu'une
parcelle des connaissances globales
les québécois en province une expression
que j'aime beaucoup c'est présent bhl je
trouve de dire même couché à soi - nba
ça veut dire que l'état de base
d'enseigner c'est pas trés sera pas plus
intelligent fallait tu sais pas des
français manquent coucher moins niaise
savait que la base là dessus ça c'est
tout le monde signé non mais c'est vrai
je serai un peu moins
oui on voit beaucoup les tirs faisant
texte cet exercice laissent pas de
traces à chaque à chaque semaine on
rencontre quelqu'un d'un milieu
complètement différent qui connaît son
sujet que oui son milieu pire chose à
faire les recherches à 20 menant jusqu'à
l'entrevue où la conversation puis
pendant la conversation on apprend en
apprend chaque semaine énormément
vraiment si ce mot si c'est pareil pour
toi ça fait des années que je peux à
l'école puis j'ai l'impression de chaque
semaine de revenir sur les bancs d'école
d'avoir un croisement des gens
exactement
c'est une façon de voyager c'est quand
on faisait à l'époque les voyages
forment la jeunesse mais aujourd'hui le
l'univers est mondialisée donc tu peux
rencontrer plein de gens en étant sur
place là qui vont emmener en voyage dans
ce qu'ils font
non ce qu'il pense dans ce qu'ils
cherchent puis je pense que c'est comme
ça qu'on grandit
collectivement c'est l'intelligence
individuelle les scientifiques nous ont
parlé beaucoup de ça c'est l'individu en
gras quotient intellectuel est
intelligent mais c'est pas la valeur -
c'est de savoir cumulatif vraiment 17-13
anthropologue qui est importante
le savoir relative c'est bâtir à partir
de ce que nos prédécesseurs
prédécesseurs ont construit parce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui partie des héros on
arrive dans un univers où les jacques
cartier sont arrivés ici ils ont
rencontré les iroquoiens qui ont leur
donner des trucs qui nous aurait tous
crever c'est hier un chercheur américain
qui appelle ça le rappel salle je
pensais pas un syndrome est le 2 le
l'explorateur repeint le l'explorateur
harper disait si tu prends l'individu le
plus intelligent de la terre et eu la
même dans un environnement où tu connais
personne n'ait rien il a beau être
einstein va crever c'est vrai et les
explorateurs à la fin car ils sont
partis à l'époque l'europe secret comme
le nombril du monde ces îles classées
les gens aspirent n'estimez j'appelle ça
le pâté chinois là le blanc à eau le
jaune au milieu puis le brun en bas puis
nous sommes les plus intelligents c'est
tout les britanniques puis sont rendus
compte que partout où ils vont ils vont
trouver un savoir cumulatif qui est
totalement différent du leur pour le
mans et toutes les fois où ils ont
refusé de tendre la main à ces gens
l'exprit l'expédition de france en étant
ceux qui voulaient découvrir le passage
du nord-est et ils sont partis à
l'époque où l'angleterre sur quoi est le
nombril du monde avec leurs grosses
lainage ils ont dit on s'en va on n'a
pas besoin des inuits pour ça on est
assez intelligente et assez fort
l'angleterre pour le fait qu'ils ont
tous crever les unités ont vu dans des
scènes de cannibalisme des derniers le
bouffer les uns les autres à l'orgue
hammond scène le norvégien qui a décidé
de le faire il a dit je vais aller
m'approprier de savoir cumulatif des
inuits des gens du nord
ils connaissent plein de choses qu'on
connaît pas et la première chose qui a
appris c'est de faire des attelages de
chiens d'élever des chiens de les
appeler d'aller avec les chiens et il a
appris aussi que les vêtements la grosse
laine européenne rohs porte et là
c'était pas chaud comparé à scorer les
élus et ça devient alors les inuits ont
rendu en août scène intelligente même si
on disait que c'est ça en fait et je
pense que c'est ça quand on rencontre
des gens on les écoute c'est ça que ça
fait c'est qu'on augmente on s'approprie
le savoir cumulatif et j'en passe pour
moi c'est ça qui est plus important que
l'individu oui et c'est ce qui fait que
les humains et on se démarque parce que
c'est en soi un email
tu le mets dans la nature dans une forêt
en niveau 6 fois on n'est pas fort
physiquement vraiment on ne pose on n'a
pas des moindres détails peuvent t on
est en face à face à un ours un lion et
on se fait détruire
sauf qu'on est devenus les plus grands
prédateurs de la planète
oui ma cause à cause justement de la
manière compte capables de s'organiser
puis en train de lire le livre sapiens
c'est une des détails justement c'est
que l'humain par l'humain rien puis même
que son compère de savoir avec le savoir
des humains de du temps des chasseurs
cueilleurs nos cerveaux serait pas pu
développer peut-être même moins
développés parce qu'on n'a plus besoin
d'avoir vraiment tant de connaissances
notre environnement dessus parce que
toutes les connaissances nécessaires
sont dans notre téléphone tous les
livres les bibliothèques te ment c'est
donc on a un magazine - dans notre
propre cerveau oui mais quand tu cumules
tout le monde ensemble comment qu'on
partage mais tant qu'internet peut avoir
toute l'information est interné
mais en tant qu'espèce on la connaît en
mauricie désarroi et la force notre
force est dans le réseau ouais et que
l'autre animal je crois qu'ils capables
de s'organiser
de cette manière le lobby de partager
aux tentes et de toiles et les fourmis
toi vote des animaux qui organisent
ensemble mais aussi d'être capable de de
se réorganiser tout le temps au titre
sur garde à travers l'utilisation à
travers les époques plus mince et
capable de avec son environnement
complètement changé la manière dont
s'organise et s'ils habitent dans nord
10 minutes dans sa gamme d'une certaine
façon si on est dans tes dents tel que
dans tel milieu il veut développer le
type d'agriculture que j'étais rohff
accessoire intéressant local du maillon
ni mallet at oui malherbe mai
oui c'est vrai ce que tu dis c'est notre
foi c'est le réseau dans les hôtels de
nos cerveaux j'écoutais un documentaire
qui parlait des pieuvres les pieuvres
ont vraiment une bonne capacité à
transmettre la connaissance alors leurs
enfants oui chacun étant la pub à l
apprend quelque chose plus capable de le
transmettre à ses enfants puis il disait
que malheureusement cette année des
dépôts cas de garder sur une base
sociétaires donner une base de données
c'est exact ça recommençait tout le
temps oui expliqué que si les pluies ont
été capables de collectivement se
rappeler de l'information se rappeler de
la façon 9 heures les plus les pieuvres
pour leur potentiel d'évoluer rapidement
parce qu'incapable de transmettre leurs
informations que de façon effective à
leurs enfants
voilà c'est ça il y aurait fallu qu'ils
inventent la machine à écrire est exact
c'est ça mais même ceux qui n'avaient
pas inventé la machine à écrire celle
est qui qui qui si on raconte je pense
c'est dans le même bouquin mais ou alors
à hergé les vues mais il fallait un peu
de le chef d un calme quand cortes a
rencontré le grand chef
parce qu en amérique du sud l'amérique
centrale il y avait des armes et de plus
c'est énorme
ils se sont fait avoir par quelques
espagnols un microbe qui sont tout ouïe
à les microbes mais il ya aussi le fait
que quelqu'un raconter que la différence
entre les deux c'est qu'elle en perd des
1/4 le chef ils savaient pas ils ne
savaient pas que les espagnols existent
et les espagnols savait que lui existe
selon le frère ennemi street and ben dis
donc tu sais qu'un ennemi mais aussi si
lui arrive puis 10 et essai de tes
invités puis ils l'ont fait dans les
airs fin tout la gagne le kop le code
local votre cas l'autre invite puis tu
viennes puis on va donner kidnapped
jacques cartier l'a fait avec le chef il
au coin d'un à kaunas et l'invite n'a le
bateau puis l'envers d'étudiants je m'en
vais avec toi c'est les gens du nord
je suis pas sûr car aucune idée de
comment l'humain peut plus agir mais
cela se fait pas on ne fait pas ça chez
nous
chez nous c'est passé vous vous vous le
saviez pas mais c'est ça la cccm animal
social
mais oui tu vois qui c'est les plus
impitoyables qui quitte sa mère quand
vraiment 101 membres est ce que personne
mais le seul qui est capable de mentir
devient oui dans l'univers du monde y en
a qui disent c'est la tricherie a fait
évoluer l'intelligence humaine
puis on a enchéri on a un bon exemple
juste au sud
oui c'est un bon exemple juste au sud de
comment le mensonge et la tricherie a
mené situation c'est exactement ça lui
on fait le décompte de ces mensonges
mais voyons non j'ai un président peut
pas être malade mais si tu prends avec
le suspens avec l'idée qu'un président
peut pas être malade est depuis que
pékin dit des trucs comme ça tu le crois
pas tu fais ben non il doit pas une
maladie c'est vrai et russe à convaincre
ceux qui disent que tu m'as qui mentent
les secours commencent à légender sur le
site apple compte chaque fois qu avec
qui tu te dis que tu m'as ça donne la
force parce que ça alimente société
cavale encore oui mais on a on essayait
de déjouer le mensonge des autres on à
développer nos capacités intellectuelles
beaucoup non humains parce que c'est que
lui devant moi la société humaine étant
une société très politique et la
politique et le mans sont ils sont
intimement liés les demi-vérités les
yeux d'alliance est alors donc on essaye
tout le temps de savoir d'anticiper que
ce qui va faire mais je pense que ça ça
fait partie des forces de l'espèce
humaine
au delà de son effectif c'est vrai c'est
petit cri culpa vite n'y a pas de grille
via pas les canines d'un examen et pages
il mais je pense que les animaux qu'ils
ont sous-estimé sont tous disparu ouais
puis justement dans ce livre ce qui est
intéressant aussi t on parler de
l'adaptation des animaux pis il fait la
liste des grands mammifères des grands
animaux qui avaient en amérique avant
qu'il soit mort
avait des animaux incroyables y avait
des jeunes hommes avec des visées paix
et d'amour il y avait comme qu'on
appelle des paresseux géant en amérique
qui mesure et tu peux même pas imaginer
mais ce qu'on a trouvé c'est que partout
où l'homme est arrivé dès qu'il est
arrivé quelques milliers d'années plus
tard la mégafaune à 10 par exemple les
plus gros les nerfs 1 ont tous disparu
sauf dans la mer parce que dans la mer
il pouvait pas vraiment quand on parle
de mégaphones gpo lui les polices les
blocs ça fait référence sur les noms -
manif à l'aide et les mammouths et les
mastodontes blé les oiseaux géants en
australie avec des oiseaux et les noms
les kiwis originaux là en fait partie
les espèces de gros gros oiseau sur
leurs doigts oui tout ça à l'écrou y
avait des lézards en australie là qui le
dragon de komodo c'était un mais à côté
de ça ah ouais c'est des plus gros qu 5
avec 1 amélie que tu avais des
mastodontes avait des paresseux géant
dans les îles il y avait des touches de
faune endémique des gros qui est à une
loi non écrite dans la nature c'est
quand je suis plus gros que toi mais tu
m'écris repas non 1 sauf pour l'espèce
humaine les animaux ne le savais pas
ouais c'est à dire que quand un mammouth
voyez un humain à côté de lui se disait
et pas assez fou pour m'attaquer
ouais mais non il était fou comme tu
disais tantôt lille veut pas mettre
enfin en réseau ils vont dire jack pot
mais allez à droite on va les chasser
vers la chute du monde tomber par terre
qui vont se casser les jambes si il
mange parce que ça ça a été la mégafaune
ça a été ça quand ils sont arrivés les
plus gros ont disparu les premiers
parrains australie l'humain est arrivé
là vers 35 mille trente sept mille
pendant cinq milles en amérique c'est ça
varie beaucoup on parce que en dc 20500
la civilisation de clovis mais qui sont
passés par le détroit de béring
maintenant les anthropologues 19h30 au
moins 80 autres
mais il met partout il arrive dans les
îles on regarde quelques milliers
d'années plus tard tout les gens sont
partis - et donc on ne peut pas ne pas
faire le lien en huit ans
on n'était pas là comme témoin mais on
soupçonne fortement que c'est aux zones
qu'ils ont tous massacrés ces
déséquilibres qui s'apprend des millions
d'années s établir si cet amour doit
évoluer il est on a un équilibre
justement qui fonctionne à l'humain
arrive puis tout s'écroule et c'est pas
juste lui c'est aussi ces animaux kg
mais n'est pas juste lui c'est que il
vient avec les chiens les chats et les
râleurs compagne aussi dans sa migration
et dans tous les endroits qui étaient
isolés et comme l'australie c'est un bel
exemple l'australie mais les gens sont
arrivés puis ont emmené les mammifères
placer les mammifères placentaires qu'on
a ici
il n'existait pas en australie c
c'étaient les marsupiaux qui ont un
système de reproduction qui est
totalement différent mais les mammifères
placentaires est en plus efficace ils
ont tous les humains qui y en a mais
bien sûr bien sûr les chiens les chats
les rats les et si ça ça fait que non
seulement ils ont causé les cats ambre
directement mais les animaux qu'ils ont
amené ont fait l'agriculture et tout ça
a fait que partout où ils sont passés là
ça a été
on le voyait si maintenant les gens
parlent beaucoup de la sixième
extinction
elle a commencé depuis longtemps comment
doit on le voit c'est vraiment
intéressant de faire la rétrospective
dans le temple dans l'histoire mais même
aujourd'hui on voit au quotidien des
espèces disparaître absolument
et puis on voit les espèces par m2 par
l'humain vraiment 26 ans à chaque à
chaque jour 15 secondes
ouais puis je me rappelais plus je n'en
peux plus c'est quoi le pourcentage des
espèces globale qui existent encore et
qui ont menacé la whey mais moi je pense
que je dis aux gens des fois se dit
c'est plus simple de dire qu'est ce qui
n'est pas menacé
ouais c'est pour cela et non parce que
la grande majorité sont menacés
avec au lieu de dire il ya 70% là qui
éprouvent des problèmes on est moins on
est mieux de dire y'en à 25% qui
s'enquérait quand tu ouvres est là parce
que c'est horrible et je veux dire c'est
un sablier qui est renversé comme ça et
malheureusement pour apa le retourner
est ce que est ce qu'il ya une sorte
d'espoir dans la dans la science elle
même pour tous qui est qui et qui est
une personne de sciences une personne de
biologie skis une certaine lueur
d'espoir dans le fait que la science un
jour va être capable de renverser ces
effets le sait on parle on parle par
exemple de clonage d'un certain niveau
avec dédé des ossements qu'on retrouve
deux capables de recréer une espèce le
post ben moi je suis tellement moi je
pense pas que la solution soit détruit
dit long non mais je vous dis jamais ton
qu'on réussit à stopper les effets en
tant que société à ralentir le pendule
est déjà lancé oui est-ce qu'il ya
malgré tout une espèce d'espoir de
peut-être qu'un jour on peut revenir un
bain je pense que oui je pense qu'on est
quand même outillés pour faire certaines
choses mais il reste qu'il faut pas
oublier que la demande majorité des
espèces ce sont des cdd organismes que
la nature a mis des millions d'années à
finir à fignoler mai et qui fait
parfaitement dans leur environnement
l'humain c'est pâques c'est pas un
animal qui est il est capable du
meilleur et du pire parce qu'au moins
les graines c'est la végétation
il ya aujourd'hui des banques enfui dans
le pergélisol à l'autre bout du monde là
où on met toutes les graines en disant
au kazoo même moment donné peut-être
qu'on pourra m'amener ça se peut qu'on
ait besoin de ça parce qu'on ne sait pas
mais pour les animaux
honnêtement c'est plus complexe pour les
animaux une espèce qui disparaît à
disparaître capacity la réussite a
laissé c'est une ou deux
c'est à dire il y en a plein comme ça
qui sont partis c'est l'exemple qu'on
donne souvent aux jeunes c'est le dodo
doigt une mauvaise idée
le dodo les marins hollandais sont
arrivés là et ont vu se creuse oiseaux
qui fait pas ou qui courent pas lyon
joue au baseball avec ça c'est les ont
massacrés et puis on raconte même qu'il
mangeait pas tant que ça parce que c'est
juste pour la forme
ici la tourte voyage s vous connaissez
l'histoire de la tour ici en amérique la
tourte les québécois disent que la
tourtière vient de ce mot là acquéreurs
qu'on mettait la chair de ce pigeon
voyageur au midi au musée redpath
laisser miguil et à une tourte leur en
parler mais si la dernière tout est
morte en 1913 dans ce cas là c'est c'est
lé plus gros rassemblement d'oiseau de
la planète
on les avait ici certains explorateurs
raconte qu'avant le xviie siècle il y en
a un
un explorateur britannique qui raconte
avoir vu passer dans le sud est des
états unis un milliard de tourtes qui
cacher le soleil pendant des heures
pendant leur migration et à un moment
donné les américains dans leur
agriculture ne semble se sont mis à les
traiter comme la vermine en disant ça
gâche les champs et ils sont mis à les
tuer en masse comics tenez sur les
beaucoup sur un hardi tirer il
organisait des concours de ty de tir et
se différentier 30 1220 un cadeau ces
îles et laisser courir les tourtes et
quand ils ont commencé à construire le
chemin de fer aux états unis ben ils ont
découvert que les ouvriers et mes seins
sont mis à l'étude pour nourrir les
contenus et à la dernière troupe
s'appelait marta elle est décédée dans
un juhasz ainsi natif puis à s'accumuler
c'est le plus grand génocide animalier
de la planète après celui du bison qu'on
a évité parce qu'à de justesse mais
c'est s'aider réalité comme ça une
tortilla n'aura plus la torte c'est fini
si quelqu'un veut le voir faut qu'ils
aillent au musée puis qui voyait un
apparat l'otan et pourtant c'était des
milliards d'individus soit sais rien
1 comparé à cela c'est fou je me
rappelle martha j'avais écrit un texte
quand j'écris pour pour des jeunes pour
les éditions passées c'était j'avais
faite aux textes des 10/10 des animaux
est un qui étaient les plus fascinants
oui je me rappelle avoir écrit sur ma
retour à la nature de la dernier la
dernière tout voyage qui était dans un
jour ça l' assassinat ti est décédé la
veille ont essayé mais gagne rien à
faire défini la dette plusieurs
milliards d'individus à un individu mais
la tourte c'est fini il ya beaucoup
d'animaux c'est comme ça aujourd'hui on
a beaucoup beaucoup qui sont sous le
respirateur artificiel puis on ne sent
pas la volonté
les gens parlent beaucoup du climat
c'est parce que le climat niveau des
mers ça nous touche nous nous
personnellement ce que les gens sont
plus avec la biodiversité
bah c'est grâce et merci lui le ca 6
on le voit et c'est on le voit tout les
glands camille voir les grands
herbivores sont sous le respirateur a
une espèce qui a réussi à semer l'espèce
humaine et qui est peut-être loi de tous
les animaux ont le sous-estiment c'est
le char le chat le chat le chat a un
pouvoir de sa sellerie sur l'espèce
humaine
tout le reste là mais le chat a réussi
il sert à rien de faire un saut lui
marié même un chien qui lui dit va
chercher sa garde la maison surveille
les vagues et donnera la pâte mais un
chat qui a réussi dans l'antiquité les
chiens on les a accusés de sorcellerie
bout
l'église avait une bulle pontificale
pour dire que les chats pactise avec le
diable le soir puis les sorcières montés
sur des chats noirs des était accompagné
les actus et licha est même en égypte
s'étaient regardés comme c'est moi le
chat était roi en egypte
les égyptiens peut-être que c'est eux
qui ont mieux compris la scion richard
pouvoirs magiques sur nous
la déesse égyptienne s'appelait bas step
avait une tête de châssis et on raconte
dans la mythologie égyptienne que à un
moment donné un gros serpent noir qui
avait avalé le soleil puis le grand dieu
a envoyé le chat pour attraper le
poisson puis lui faire recracher
le sol et les égyptiens adoré les champs
donc tu vois quand quelqu'un avait perdu
son chat il se rasaient les sourcils en
signe de deuil et quand ils cherchent à
en egypte pourrait être condamné à mort
pour ça or à l'époque les chats étaient
intouchables comme d'ailleurs je me
souviens plus quel peuple a attaqué
l'egypte et qui avait un moment donné
appris que les égyptiens il des ifi
tellement les chers qu'ils ont dit la
seule façon de les déstabiliser c'est de
les catapulter des charretiers parce que
ça va les traumatisés avec 4000 armée en
déroute s'est mis l'accent dans ce conte
qui atterrissaient toujours sur leurs 4
9 c'est vrai qu' on ne vit sa manoeuvre
catapulte pour y garder de chat
les lions c'est pas la loi de la salle
c'est le chat quand on voit des animaux
il est dans les bandes à l'eau dans les
appartements il faut absolument rien il
dort il se laisse caresser qu'en sentant
parce que lucien roy le chien il y en a
presque on parle de presque 1 milliard
de chat sur la planète et là c'est
l'animal qui en explosion démographique
partout sa planète sait on des millions
des dizaines de millions de chats
errants qui cause des excès sombre dans
la biodiversité c'est un cas rare et
puis oui c'est sainté les champs place
et c'est les seuls animaux de compagnie
qu'on peut retrouver dans nature bada
nature mais qu'on peut retrouver pas de
mise
oui sans domicile oui qui subsiste quand
même très bien mais tu sais pourquoi
parce que le chargement si le chien est
à jamais été domestiqué par l'humain
même encore il est venu tout seul c'est
lui les chiens on est allé chercher des
loups les loups des bébés bout pour les
acclimater on est allé chercher lavage
vient dans la roche
on l'a fait le cochon vient du sanglier
le mouton vient du mouflon si on les a
domestiqué changer le chat il est venu
tout seul à la maison et on a trouvé ça
intéressant parce qu'on commençait
l'agriculture mais on avait des greniers
puis des souris maginot récolte les
challenges et les souris et tout et on a
dit on et contacts
il est très bon il donne pas la patte
ils nous emmerdent mais on va l'accepter
quand même c'est lui qui nous aider mais
ce qui est en fait voilà exactement
l'humain est un animal domestiqué par
les glaces il ne sait pas il ne sait pas
parce qu ils sont là il faut leur tirer
bien il se couche
ici ils ont étoilé on a nourri soyons
tous cas besoin parce qu'ils font de
leurs journaux vincent ils sont là mais
il exerce un magnétisme jeu l'espèce
lui-même serait regardez là dans des
vidéos de choc et sur youtube salar
maintenant et même des villes qui ont
élu des sharks aubert en alaska des
chats qui hérite de millions de dollars
de leurs propriétaires des chats qui ont
des désabonner un tweeter les fastes et
les pages sur instagram déchets oui très
célèbre des fantastiques en fait ces
deux oeuvres d'art peut-être aussi
moi je sais c'est l'autre théorie que je
dis c'est que c'est le chas d'une oeuvre
d'art vivant l'instinct animal beau
vraiment il est équilibré bout il ya des
yeux magnifiques
il ya un cri qui rappelle bébé humain
c'est tout le contraire lauren conrad
lorraine était un drap éthologistes
autrichien qui a eu le prix nobel et
conrad laurent disaient les uns les
humains sont attirés par les animaux qui
ont un minois comme ça avec des yeux
ronds et qui lâche des cris qui
ressemble aux bébés humains et le chat
ça répond exactement le chat le blanchon
ville blachon tu vois comment les uns se
déchirent pour protéger des blanchons le
phoque adultes qui en ont rien à [ __ ]
mais le blanchon il y à un les yeux
ronds comme sa vitre e1 le chat c'est
exactement la même chose des ses épis le
shaik a écrit les biologistes disent que
les chats en vivant chez les humains ont
même adapter le cri pour vraiment touché
le coeur de l'urss est extrêmement
solide en bébé parce que quand tu
réfléchis petit imagine un bébé un bébé
naissant ou de quelques mois seulement
qui te regarde oui avec les grands yeux
ouverts picchi qui ripe il fait des
petits
oui ça rappelle un jeune protégé le bébé
on va l'avoir
tout le monde veut que tout aille pour
le bébé ici et le chat je pense que
c'est ça c'est une oeuvre d'art qui est
arrivé chez nous puis qui est la pile il
y a
il m'a ensorcelé l'espèce humaine comme
ça l'église avait raison six jours que
l'église lui demander de tuer les chasse
était triste et malheureux mais c'est
vrai que le chien a ensorcelé l'espèce
humaine
ouvrez là mais à un problème est sale et
l'oubli parce qu'il existe un lobby
jicha aussi les gens qui adorent le
châble ils veulent pas entendre aussi le
fait que le chat s'élever négatif que je
peux avoir les australiens et en arrache
avec les chats parce qu'il y en a des
millions en liberté ni du les petits
oiseaux les petits mammifères l'ayant
tue parce que le chat même s'il vit au
10e 10e étage sur un immeuble à condos
de luxe qu'ils descendent en baïse et
encore comment chercher de la faire non
taleb un prédateur des déchets les
normes et il retourne à l'état sauvage
c'est le seul le sel quand tu peux
retourner l'appui a aucun problème parce
que c'était les gens qui sont les laits
vegan connais toi là s'est il y en a
beaucoup qui disent il faut libérer les
animaux c'est à libérer les animaux
m'étais libéraux et en aucun qui
survivront
mais non ces animaux là qui demande de
libérer il existe par nature la vache
l'a jamais qui sont en scène alain roche
en partie a longtemps la vache c'est pas
commun même les chiens il y a libéré les
moutons et l'on voit c'est l'école on
s'en tape et bisons finir c'est chiant
lui échappe à sa musique
mais ça c'est un c'est un paradoxe qui
est extrêmement intéressant même là la
philosophie vegan des animaux de
compagnie par exemple oui qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ceux ci ont cité c'est
quoi le sais quoi c'est quoi la la la
façon d'aborder cette question le cpie
j'écoutais
un gars sur qui s'appelle kling aide qui
fait des vidéos illustrent vegan qui
fait des vidéos à caractère
philosophique du véganisme puis explique
lui explique que c'est demain matin et
tu prends un chihuahua sur le tutu l'âge
d'or puis il fait 2 jours même politique
c'était un entraînement avec les cordes
qui rentrent en ville c'est ce qu'il va
faire exact puis piqué toutes ces
espèces le c'est vraiment la philosophie
vegan va au maximum qui est de ne pas
exploiter animaux puis on s'attend que
les animaux de compagnie province sur
laisse le choix nécessairement préféré
ne pas être puis piste et laisse partir
c'est juste terminée pour toutes ces
espèces oui c'est la même chose que
comme tu disais pour tout les animaux
d'élevage
le cochon papale paul cauchon le wild
boar ne pas sangliers mais le cochon le
pôle qu'on mange le port de québec lui
aucune chance
alors si tu n'es pas capable de marcher
ils paient trop gros il est ouest est
fake
toutes ces espèces le si la philosophie
vegan vaut à son comble son vouée à
l'extinction complète puis c'est un peu
contradictoire de penser se dit
maintenant qu'elle est là c'est qu'elle
est là si tu as la solution pour se
sortir de soutien en tant que vegan que
les notes la façon qu'on peut aborder la
question comment vous voulez faire ça je
pense que je pense que la ligue ait dit
vous voulez faire soit la réponse je
crois que c'est juste en entier en
faisant une transition jusqu'à
éventuellement elle capable de peut
peut-être faire des élevages qui sont
pas dédiés à la consommation qui sont
pas dédiés à la terminale it et de la
vie qui fait que déjà évoquées on a
amené la situation là par notre part nos
choix nous de domestiquer 2
faire génétiquement modifiés des espèces
qui sont rendus complètement inapte à la
vie sauvage fait maintenant on va dealé
avec des conséquences de nos propres
décisions peut on va les éleveurs un
corps mais pas autant donner les noms
vision dramatique complètement non
éthique puis dans des conditions qui
vont juste vivre leur vie tu vois c'est
un questionnement que j'avais bien qu'on
a reçu jean-philippe ce qui était un
chef vegan way qui en fait les plus
grands porte parole qui oppose les
gardes qui sait si j'ai posé des
questions mais tous ces animaux là les
cochons les vaches les animaux d'élevage
si on suit tout le monde vient vegan
n'existe rompu on n'aura plus besoin
d'eux puis il y en aurait pu qui me
répondit oui mais c'est quand tu es
petit tu es poney peut pas souffrir
il a raison sur un sens qui est que ces
animaux les îles nice pour vivre une vie
de souffrance et c'est comme si moh chic
et mettons six jeux pour mettre un
enfant au monde en ce moment par exemple
si je sais qu'il va vivre dans des
conditions de vie exécrables
j'aurais attendu qu'il m'attendait dans
une meilleure position au saut pour
l'espoir de donner la meilleure vie
possible
puis ils se reposent celui qui est
paniquée ponétie jamais ni chez lui
accorde à cette formule c'est ce qui est
du point de vue de telle espèce bello
oui c'est triste parce que ce n'est pas
ce que disparaît mais au moins les
individus csp selon benjamin moi je sais
que c'est sûr que c'est une philosophie
qui touche les à des gens qui que ça
habitent très profondément
et c'est un sujet qui est très divisée
parce que énormément beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mais je pense que c'est ça va
prendre du temps
ben oui non non ça va ça va prendre des
civilisations qui sont plus proches de
sac
que nous que la civilisation occidentale
mettons là pendant les six autres sont
habitués mais qu'ont vécu les gens au
végétarisme pour le domaine moi je pense
que la première chose qu'on devrait
essayer peut-être de promouvoir c'est un
élevage et responsable sur belval de
proximité de dire aux jambes et aux
caisses il a bien fait partie de votre
nourriture
peut-être qu'on deviendra travailler
collectivement améliorer le bien-être
animal qui l'amélioré commencer par ça
parce que de penser je regarde moi je
regarde ça de l'extérieur et je regarde
cette discussion pas comme le climat le
climat est à des jeunes qui sont très
près une gauche un peu extrême qu'il
faut changer tout radicalement restera
pas mais pour l'heure 7 pouces ce
domaine là c'est pareil mais je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux de commencer par
dire aux gens faisons mieux la cie
essayons de responsabiliser les gens
puis de juste juste d'être conscient
qu'un animal ayant des émotions les
animaux qu'il faut pas oublier ça
maintenant et je défie quiconque de lire
le dernier livre dauphin de france
lalande val qui écrit beaucoup sur les
grands singes qui a écrit l'émotion
animal puis de se rendre compte que ça
existe c'est puis tout ce qu'on pensait
que ça n'existe pas chez les animaux on
se rend compte que même les rares ou une
intelligence extraordinaire
ils sont contents qu'ils comprennent des
choses qui sont conscients de ce qu'ils
vivent des fois les hauts murs anti
douleur qu'on y met dans l'eau
bouillante
les remarques mais j'imagine moi je dis
aux blancs si vous pensez que ça fait
pas mal de toute façon prenez un petit
ma forme optimale les piments forts est
au blanc ce que la cuisson et au romarin
cette couleur tu as compris
mais si je veux dit dans l'hésitation on
on comment je pourrais dire sale l on ne
sait pas c'est quand c'est par là quand
tu regarde des vidéos des européens dans
le passé les français par exemple
comment ils se comporter avec les
animaux les anguilles vivant puis et le
truc même des émissions de télé où tu
vois l'animal en lui tendant la main
dans l'assiette et la sas était étudié
ou non non ça peut pas être ça c'est
manquer de respect au caractère sacré de
la vie aussi ça c'est un bon mois mais
il ya un équilibre à atteindre en
plaidant entre le véganisme way et le
cannibalisme extrême il ya un équilibre
qui doit peut-être mener à une
diminution de progresser moi c'est mon
combo que oui j'essaie d'amener une
diminution
ouais que tout le monde passe à son
propre rythme parce que le moindrement
con con qu'on diminue la demande
tranquillement love a changé
tranquillement les méthodes si les
industries ont pu besoin de fournir
moins un de façon industrielle de
débattre sur milliards d'animaux par
année et piquent leur peut-être les
conditions vont devenir meilleur puis
c'est déjà un peu la direction optimale
équilibre dans toute chose c'est l'
équilibre que ça prends moi je pense que
les deux extrêmes menacent et c'est très
dur c'est très rare que les deux
extrêmes soit la solution xi ainsi c'est
dans une discussion passe de la vie
c'est au simple que ça se passe
ça veut dire il faut que je crée accepte
de se déplacer vers l'autre puis on
trouve une solution de compromis au
centre et peut-être que la transition se
ferait comme ça aussi il ya les deux les
deux parties ont raison c'est quand
j'entends des fois des ja dv gamme qui
sont très calmes très militant l'attend
andy dans l'humain c'est pas un chasseur
c'est mais oui lui met un chercheur du
mais la tâche à ça c'est fait c'est un
qu'ailleurs c'est un pêcheur ça a
toujours été ça 6,7 millions d'années
qu'ils mangent de la viande
mais la quantité qui manger avant parce
que je pense que la théorie du chasseur
qui courent après le mammouth avec une
roche qui atteint c'est un peu exagéré
on peut semer un secret la viande a fait
partie de l'espèce humaine puis quand on
s'intéresse aux sciences de l'évolution
qui on regarde ça de très près on se
rend compte que même notre physiologie a
changé à cause de de la viande mais
aussi des produits marins c'est les gens
manger du poisson il ya une frange des
biologistes de l'évolution équipe qui
milite pour le riva ccd qu'ailleurs de
coquillages et des mangeurs de poisson
et un prof de l'université de sherbrooke
a une théorie extraordinaire là dessus
qui dit que peut-être l'intelligence
nous vient beaucoup plus des produits de
la mer que de la chasse dont on parle
souvent
sauf qu'ils ont aussi un pas que l'image
ainsi que les plantes aussi un pas qu'on
l'ait myspace faut que je te le dire
j'en profite pour te dire que les
plantes on les a sous-estimé beaucoup
est ce que les plans de son 100ème sont
quoi sont sans cesse qu'ils ressentent
conscients les émotions mais les plantes
n'aime pas les prédateurs aussi moi je
vis les plantes n'aime pas ça c'est sûr
que nous on a toujours gardé les plantes
comme des espèces figé dans la terre et
qui végète
quand quelqu'un fait rien on dit végète
j'ai pris du temps mais aujourd'hui si
tu savais la quantité de choses qu'on
découvre sur les plans sur leur capacité
à se défendre sur leur tout les
alcaloïdes que les fonds les plantes ont
développé pour se protéger des gens qui
l'image
la caféine café caféine la théine ce
sont deux alcaloïdes qui ont été
développés par des plantes de la famille
du café pourquoi et pour tuer les
parasites pour tuer les parasites qui
les mangent chez nous on est l'espèce
humaine et dépendantes aux drogues
développé par les plans disais mais a
beaucoup ce qu'on appelle les huiles
essentielles c'est beaucoup
des molécules qui ont été développés par
les plantes pour dire aux animaux qui
n'ont pas un rôle dans leur cycle ne
mangeait pas en parler on parlait depuis
mon enfance
voilà là c'est la même chose à la
capsaïcine des piments
au début ça a été beaucoup pour
contrôler les micro-organismes c'est les
champignons les bactéries dans la
nourriture mais les mammifères qui n'ont
aucun rôle dans le cycle du piment ben
ils se font piquer par la partie
capsaïcine mais les oiseaux qui
disséminent les graines de blé noir et
qui les font germer ailleurs cédé a mis
du piment donc la capsaïcine touche pas
les oiseaux mais qui nous bouzzine aux
autres dans la bouche mais tu sais que
maintenant on a découvert que les
plantes tout ce qu'on pensait exclusive
aux animaux quasiment existe chez les
plantes c'est juste un principe de
survie c'est pas compliqué l'objectif
c'est de perpétuer et et gêne aussi en
grande partie donc on a trouvé même des
plantes urd animaux qui tire d une
expérience qui a été fait en afrique du
sud où on prenait des coups d'où le coup
du ciné-club d'afrique du sud puis le
gars il voulait faire de l'élevage de
coup double donc qui les a mis dans un
enclos puis il y avait des acacias dans
l'enclos puis les coudes ou commis le
mal des acacias il s'est rendu compte
que les animaux qui étaient dans
l'enclos b mais glisse et puis comme ça
immigrés ce ville de la nourriture qui à
un moment donné les animaux sont morts
puis là ils font des contenus stomacaux
pouvoir ce qui s'est passé puis se
rendre compte que les feuilles d'acacia
n'ont pas été vraiment bien digérée par
les animaux peas ont eu raison qu'est ce
qui se passe est là en analysant les
feuilles d'acacia il se rend compte que
les feuilles d'acacia été très très
concentré en tanins toxiques et pourquoi
parce que les acacias
quand le coude ou manger l'acacia ici
l'acacia envoyer des informations aux
autres spéciales dans la direction du
vent pour le dit préparez vous à des
prédateurs qui arrivent des broutards et
les autres à casser à synthétiser des
tanins toxiques et les concentrés dans
leurs feuilles
ils ont tué les animaux ça ça existe et
père plein d'autres des plantes qui sont
capables de reconnaître des membres de
leur famille par les racines des grands
mamans qui partagent avec les petits
petit en bas des plantes qui sont
capables d'avoir une certain sens du
sang de l'aude a essayé c'est fascinant
bien un livre qui a été écrit par un
un physiologiste italien qui s'appelle
l'intelligence des plans c'est c'est
quelque chose là la seule différence
maintenant parce que c'était dit tantôt
que les plantes ne pas être mangé la
seule différence avec les animaux c'est
que les animaux quand tu leur prends 50%
ils vont mourir si quelqu'un venait la
fuite coupe au milieu sauf que les
plantes ils peuvent perdre jusqu'à 90%
de leur parti vite et appuie romain
serait à pousser
donc on peut leur en prendre quand même
voilà mais voici c'est la première fois
que j'entends ça
cc c'est fascinant qu'est ce que qu'est
ce qu'on fait c'est en tant qu'humain et
on ne l'a on a un devoir moral parce
qu'on a la capacité de discerner la
morale on a cette capacité là qui est
pas une capacité qui quitte à tous les
animaux qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on a
ce devoir là si on prend en
considération justement tient au niveau
des animaux si on prend en considération
qu'on n'a pas le droit de cros qui ont
le droit de survivre si on prend la
considération avec ce que tu viens dire
que les plantes aussi ont ce droit là
dans la survie à la le désir non gérés
par exemple j'ai pas parlé de droit j'ai
juste dit en fait que intérêts aplomb
sans quoi les jeux disons que le besoin
de se perpétuer
l'intérêt ouais survie à la survie oui
les plantons sens et si on considère que
toutes ces espèces le que sur le plan to
d'animaux ont l'intérêt à survivre et
que nous on a un devoir moral en tant
que cani moreau qu'est ce qu'on fait ben
n'a pas abusé de bras dans les deux sens
une chaîne alimentaire c'est ça c'est
chacun mange celui qui le précède et
devient la nourriture de celui qui le
suit et à la fin il reste les super
prédateur à quelle personne ne touche qu
elle pas mais les super prédateur ben
généralement dans une chaîne alimentaire
y en a pas autant que ceux qui sont en
bas
sinon ce serait une catastrophe l'humain
lui sert aux produits il y en a donc le
blog il est là si je veux dire
si on veut nourrir combien de milliards
dont les projections dans l'ue à harare
- il parlait de combien de chasseurs
cueilleurs il y avait sur la terre l'ami
avoir la sédentarisation et à dix mille
ans au néolithique
ces tests et des petits n'ont pas
beaucoup le million il ya maintenant une
terre où tu as une population de super
prédateur incessamment d'accord et c'est
pas juste assez que le super prédateur
en question c'est un insatisfait il est
flanqué d'une génétique d'insatisfaction
parce qu'un ours polaires l' image du
phoque puis mardi faute
il compte en y incluant phoques marbrés
ou est il sans pif de la grèce puis le
lendemain c'est la semaine suivante il
tient aux phoques marbrés puissant plus
de sessa l'humain lui c'est ici un tarif
et il faut tout vous toujours que le
sushi il veut manger du de la gazelle il
veut manger du poisson ils vont manger
de temps il va essayer ça et ils vont
ramasser le plus possible c'est à dire
que jamais satisfait même cas et à un
milliard il en veut plus il y en a sept
le problème clown à l'espèce humaine
pour moi c'est ça c'est la génétique
d'insatisfaction bon on en veut tout le
temps tout en toute âme et on ramasse
notre part on ramasse la part des autres
et on emmagasine ça on emmagasine pour
pouvoir vivre y en a quatre qui ont pour
vivre mille ans c'est alors qu'ils ont
une espérance de vie de 60 en mars mais
il y en aura masse et 52 milliards et
continue à raser des forêts pourra
ramasser encore puis moi je pense que
c'est là qu'il faudrait travailler moi
c'était désactivé je sais pas comment
faire la génétique d'insatisfaction de
l'humain bien qu'on était justement à
l'époque je sens qu ailleurs on était un
petit nombre
puis on était dans dans cette chaîne
alimentaire loeb dans l'environnement
dans cet équilibre qui avait puis on
n'avait pas encore commencé à modifier
l'équilibré on se faisait manger par les
lions oui on est on est à l'abri
prédateurs on était juste un animal
parmi d'autres à la pilule quelque chose
justement dans livres d'art à ricky
d'intérêt 106
là où tout a changé c'est caen qui est
apparue l'agriculture oui parce que
l'eau tout d'un coup on pouvait
seulement à l'époque des chansons
guerrières fait seulement manger puis
souvenirs nos besoins de ce que notre
père allemand pouvait nous produire tant
pis on pouvait pas avoir des familles
pauvres faire quinze enfants parce que
je pourrai jamais nourrir mes quinze
enfants avec ce qu'est ce que j'ai en
tout cas si tu en fais tes pointure que
la moitié maurice était arrivé ici le
lui appelle cela le piège du luxe c'est
qu'il ya une fois qu'on a commencé à
faire l'agriculture ont lu plus de
ressources plus de nourriture qu'on va
faire plus d'enfants
le feu nourri tout le monde mais la loi
n'est plus du moins qu'il faut produire
plus oui là c'est toujours plus plus en
fait plus du moins faut produire plus de
11 devient piégé pour ne plus jamais
revenir en arrière peut jamais reculer
parce que dès que dès que qu'on recule
mais les sacres ça fait qu'il y ait des
gens qui meurent de faim ça fait qu'ils
les choses et on espère à la merci de
ils y arrivent une sécheresse j'arrive
une inondation une catastrophe
climatique qui ont des gros problèmes
pour l'heure on est tous cas pas de
souvenirs besoin de tout le monde
puis lüthi luis keystone beaucoup c est
ce qu'on a vraiment amélioré la
condition humaine est ce que les humains
sont vraiment mieux vivre mieux depuis
l'agriculture lui n est pas certain
c'est parce que justement ces sites est
un luxe auquel on s'habitue très
rapidement puis s'en départir il en
devient anxieux t il chance aux caillols
n'était pas anxieux de dire je veux te
manquer de nourriture
il y en avait été le qui voit des années
à l'avancé qu'il faut que juifs que je
constate dans les greniers parce que
sinon on va on va manquer de bribes du
feq lille humains devenus anxieux qui
justement est le chemin parallèle avec
ton dernier livre que où tu parles de ta
mère est utilisé on ne construit un
bâtiment avec leur climatisé oui ce qui
construit pour call any way du luxe du
luxe qui finissent ces derniers jours
que dans le luxe aux accords en pis à
l'a dit non je vous avais pas besoin de
ça si je m'habitue à ceux ci une panne
d'électricité
je vais avoir des problèmes
frappe habib sy est ce je suis heureux
avec ce que j'ai besoin de plus
exactement c'est vraiment d'avoir
l'aluminé une autre chance d'être en
tout temps d'avoir la lucidité de
reconnaître sa voix qui n'ont si j'en ai
plus sûr toujours en vouloir plus oui il
pas besoin plein là il ya c'est une
chercheure américain qui s'appelle
michael biedermann a développé une
théorie là-dessus
l'insatisfaction chronique génétique
quasiment chez lui mais c'est ça qui
nous a fait venir les satisfactions
chronique chronique ce boulet si c'est
ça qui a développé notre intelligence en
grande partie on parlais tantôt de la
ruse le marrant je suis mais
l'insatisfaction nous a poussés à nous
gratter le coco l'insatisfaction et la
peur de la mort nous ont amenés sur le
chemin de tout le temps gratter la tête
peuvent pour dire à courteille gelé un
petit bateau mais il le bateau ivoire n
1 ici des faux que j'aime les autres
fonctionnent très bien vendre quelque
chose pour aller plus vite le travail et
les rames après ça oui et il faut qu'ils
soient plus gros tu fais encore
satisfaits doit y mettre un moteur
rhénan et comme le moteur trois moteurs
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à des énormes
bateaux mais on n'est pas encore
satisfait pas fini et donc il ya ça ici
à la peur de la mort ils ont un gros
cerveau qui est hyperactif le cerveau
humain c'est 2% de la masse du corps et
consomme 20% de l'énergie c'est quelque
chose ça c'est énorme et chez les
enfants c'est encore plus ses -2 2% et
ça consomme jusqu'à 73% blé nergie chez
les bébés tout le gras qu'on développe
les bébés dont bulletins oui et donne
mais le graët vienne gras quand ils
viennent au monde mais tous grasset au
métabolisme cerveau
c est donc ce cerveau la hyperactif
aussi c'est que il est capable des plats
de retourner dans le passé se projeter
dans le futur ce qui n'est pas très
certain pour les autres animaux et nous
on voit le futur et on voit la mort
allégeance et puis on vous l'a repoussée
parce que ça nous terrorisent depuis
l'aube des temps c'est on n'a pas changé
ça et on essaye tout le talent de
c'était la médecine la magie noire la
pharmacie on a inventé thèmes matures
juste vous avez des notions et c'est là
on parle du transhumanisme
et les googlers compagnies investissent
maintenant beaucoup pour dire écoute la
mort c'est pas une fatalité
c'est un ennemi ouais et il faut leur
poussée comme on a repoussé les maladies
et c'est ça il me dit qu'il ose en même
temps mais nenê qui considère vraiment
comme une maladie oui j'écoute et si
david sinclair qui s'appelle sur
chercheurs d'horreur qui fait qu'ils
étudient le vieillissement
oui comment repousser le gameplay ont
réussi à renverser les effets du
vieillissement sur la levure
oui fait que fait qu'ils sont capables
de la levure qui est un organisme vivant
vont ils réussir à renverser les effets
du vieillissement plus sont en train de
travailler pour être capable de ralentir
peut-être renverser le vieillissement
chez les humains ab oui mais faire
tellement de projets là dessus tout ça
si si c'est ça va plus loin que ça les
gens ils parlent même maintenant de tout
enregistrer ton cerveau complice moi
aussi je sais avec la grande classe c
est aussi l aime unitaire c'est tout
c'est vraiment le transhumanisme y a le
vent dans les voiles et les grandes
entreprises ont compris que ce qui
terrorise le plus l'espèce humaine c'est
de mourir c'est fini il a terminé 6e 52
milliards puis là des vinyles des mines
et alors il faut les ramasser de
l'argent à mes gardes si tu leur dis
donnez moi les 50 milliards et tu va
revivre encore plus longtemps ils vont
te le donne et imagine celui qui va
trouver ça un point de vue individuel
cette alléchante intéressante c'est
horrible mais jamais mourir oui métier
je peux comprendre l'attrait pour
plusieurs d'été mon esprit ma conscience
vacances une existence un ordinateur où
je veux rester jeune toute ma vie mais
point de vue de l'espèce du point de vue
de la planète justement on parlait d'
équilibre tantôt qu'est ce que ça vaut
quoi qu'est ce que ça va faire de
l'ombre à moi j'aimerai pas être là pour
voir mon complice et moi je te prends
congé maladie mais d'avoir une villa
petit resto à tourner les pouces
c'est qui c'est coluche qui disait ça
ils l'éternité c'est long je suis tout
vers la force avons comparé à savoir
qu'on va mourir au système est un moteur
à vivre et oui à faire quelque chose
de vouloir que ton passage chanteur soit
un sens on dirait quelque chose c'est
parce que tu sais que contre pull up et
on est tous vraiment l'instinct de soi
des créations de procréation et on veut
faire des enfants pour pour passer nos
jeunes
on veut créer une oeuvre artistique
parce que tu faisais avant mais
survivent à continuer dans la peinture
et l'entente est on est on est tous ceux
qui nient qu'ils nous qui nous multi
s'il n'y avait pas la voir à créer la
vie ouais la diversité 99.99 pour cent
de toutes les espèces à paris sur la
planète ont disparu si on est là c'est
parce qu'on est chance on a eu des
ancêtres qui se sont reproduits jusqu'à
nous mais quand tu regardes dans
l'évolution pour les gens qui aiment les
sciences de l'évolution c'est la mort
qui fait qu'on est là 3 parce que c'est
laid au jurassique l'espèce de grosses
roches en partie on pense qui est tombé
à culoz bladen au nouveau-mexique cycle
qui a précipité la disparition des
dinosaures en partie ces c'est ça qui si
les dinosaures étaient encore là là
probablement que nous on ne serait pas
ici un porte-cartes de tricératops melo
c'est ce que dit c'est que les
mammifères y existait à l'époque mais
les mammifères c'était des c'était des
hri les dinosaures avaient occupé tout
l'espace là l'air la terre les mères
étaient partout les mammifères n'avait
pas de place les mammifères les lic
non je pense être enceinte justement de
l'époque 19 ans quittait même face à une
genre de petite loutre oui c'est des
petits dénivelés nocturne c'est des
petits animaux qui sortait la nuit parce
qu'il ne voulait pas de réinstaller le
megalodon qui faisait foi la grosseur
c'est donc la disparition des dinosaures
qui a permis l'explosion des mammifères
30 et l'explosion si les mêmes effets si
les dinosaures n'avait pas disparu
on a créé toute la gamme quasiment les
gros parce qu'il reste encore les poules
et les petits dinosaures volant se
donner les boules les oiseaux est un
oiseau quand il a dit oui mais on
apprend maintenant quelques pas des
dinosaures avaient pas vraiment des
plumes
voilà les photos imaginait de irex avec
des plombs tirés contre aix avec les
bras comme ceux de laisser des plumes ce
groupe c'est un gros chalet avait fait
des poulets sans plumes c'est génétique
mapic à tous les regards
tu voyais que ces deux dinosaures c'est
sous ce nom mais c'est ça c'est la
disparition du dinosaure qui appelle bio
au moins faire d'exploser donc c'est la
mort des dinosaures mais quand tu
regardes les plantes qui nous
nourrissent les plantes à fleurs les
plantes à fleurs aussi c'est pas ça pas
toujours été là là les forêts du
carbonifère là c'était des forêts des
forêts peuplées par des plantes qui
n'étaient pas des plantes à fleurs et
les plantes à hauts revenus et donc
c'est la disparition de ce plan à cause
d'un changement climatique qui a fait
que les plantes à fleurs sont ont
explosé les plantes à fleurs qu'on ait
ces plantes des ports et du carbonifère
c'est eux qui nous ont donné à peu près
les gisements de gaz c'était la
transformation de ces plantes mais aussi
des certains sédiments milieu marin a
généré le pétrole qu'on exploite
aujourd'hui donc c'est la mort qui a
créé le putter c'est une hécatombe créé
le pétrole et le gaz des hydrocarbures
fossiles et il faut pas oublier ça quand
on les exploite faut pas l'oublier
et donc c'est ça qui a fait que les
plantes à fleurs qui ont fait
l'explosion de la de l'homo sapiens
parce que c'est pas compliqué là c'est
les céréales tirent le diable c'est les
graminées et l'uimm est c'est un animal
domestiqué par les graminées on a parlé
du chat temps plein il est domestiqué
par les graminées aussi les plantes
il les a sous-estimé mais en réalité
toute sa vie a été manipulé par les
plans climats toute sa vie ils ont pris
les océans ils sont allés pourquoi nous
sommes ici au québec parce qu'un gars
qui s'appelait jacques cartier qui est
venu ici chercher quoi jacques cartier
les épaisses et chercher des épices mais
oui l'histoire que l'on cherchait des gp
signant kabuki arrivé ici chercher des
épices
c'est tout sur la planète les humains
les plantes c'est ensuite ils nous ont
sous-estimé et moi je dis souvent je
suis en train d'écrire un bouquin
là-dessus qui s'appelle le disciple des
plantes parce que il oublie mais en
réalité tout dans toutes les sociétés où
tu vas regarde les grecs qu'ils
adoraient l'olivier le blé avec le dieu
du logis les dieux du blé les les
japonais ont le dieu de riz durée les
chinois en sellerie les africains c'est
le millet et ont pris les plantes on a
toutes nos rituels qui sont conditionnés
par les plantes mais en même temps les
néglige pas ce qu'ils marchent pas mais
les plans ils sont dix probablement pour
investir homo sapiens ouais il va faire
la job est la mondialisation de la
végétation c'est l'humain qui l'a fait
ils n'ont pas besoin de bouger ils ont
tous amenés regarde la flore ici tu vas
voir là les plantes indigènes et en a
pas tant que ça ces tirs gardant toutes
les îles hawaï quand les gens arrivent
l'aï dit oh mon dieu regarde c'est une
végétation exotique mais non c'est à
toutes ces plantes la grande majorité
des plantes qui ont été amenées par
sapiens probablement les 10 heures je
connais pas beaucoup le monde végétal
ici là mais à plein de choses que tu
vois ici que tu penses que c'est des
plantes indigènes mais ça ne sont pas
l'exemple que je donne souvent c'est le
pissenlit c'est le pissenlit viens pas
dit si c'est les européens qui ont amené
ici vient des plaines de l'eurasie le
titre a bien marché que 100 livres avoir
réussi à bien mon gars le pissenlit
s'est développé parce qu'il est très
fort il ya des capacités ceux qui
survivent à lui mais ceux qui ont des
capacités d'adaptation les biologistes
ont démontré que le pissenlit et s'est
adaptée même au passage de la tondeuse
le fin semaine en abolissant lâché
passage de temps de hisser fleurir et
dire aux enfants regardez moi comme un
champignon souffler sur dessus et ils
savent au colonisé d'autres territoires
c'est fantastique comment les plantes
nous ont manipulés dans l'histoire
c'était car un essai puis c'est ça et on
n'est pas conscient on dit ça on dit
qu'on est très très intelligent
et l'intelligence c'est pas juste de 18
résoudre des équations mathématiques
sait se débrouiller avec ce qu'on a et
les plans étaient enracinés ils ont ils
ont trouvé des solutions extraordinaire
pour résoudre leurs problèmes de cécité
de ses six littéraire comment les
plantes manipulent les insectes
pollinisateurs oui un oui dans des
ententes les orchidées mystifie les
abeilles les filles avaient j'ai vu des
images de man sur le documentaire que je
parlais tout à l'heure de la planète sur
netflix
si une plante qui laisse rentrer des
abeilles pour les abeilles jouent dans
plantes
oui le la planta à se ferme sur les
abeilles sauf que allez allez oui cela
fait je serais intéressé oui allégresse
plus tu voi avait à charge art couverte
d comme deux pôles et vole le sac ou un
peuple à s'en veut placer sur un autre
plan m
c'est surprenant la cour la co évolution
c'est à dire que la nature a fignolé des
espèces pour manipuler d'autres et les
copies de toute beauté 4 quand tu vois
cet écart ans et c'est ce qui rend
encore plus malheureux
oui notre traitement de ceux à notre
traitement de tout ce qui nous entoure
après des millions des millions d'années
justement que par la sélection naturelle
qui tel trait ou telles mutations
aléatoires fait que telle espèce prixtel
branche voyez ça ça a fonctionné ça a
été un succès et on fignole exact
exactement ce qui fonctionne pas il
marre et je leur ai pas parlé des deux
co évolution en face en revenant ici jeu
tellement content c'est écrire mais vous
voyez les orchidées les plantes qui
récompense les plantes c'est son trait
fin et les insectes pollinisateurs
ils sont payés un hectare en pollen
riche en protéines et images qui te fait
content que tu viens là tu apprends
d'une partie tu as fait condé l'autre
moi je vais me paie trip tout le monde
est content les orchidées c'est des
tricheurs
si la population si la terre était
peuplée d'orchidées ce serait
catastrophique pour les insectes
pollinisateurs parce que leur guide et
il mystifie l'insecte pollinisateur
duty table tu vois les ya des orchidées
qu'on appelle les orchidées abel lafleur
ressemble tellement à la femelle d'une
abeille que calme alary et a
l'impression que c'est une femelle
donc il va pour s'accoupler n'est ce pas
et il donne son pollen privatives ou va
faire qu'on délocalise une autre mais ne
peut rien y en assez des arrivées n'ose
imaginer toutes ces concepts le les hlm
ses besoins de viande de lady gaga
ouais ouais j'ai un mac en ivoire pour
l'attraper puis le mans est exact exact
oui mais c'est mais c'est ça la beauté
de la nature je pense qu'il faut amener
aux jeunes en leur disant regarde
regarde comment des millions d'années
comme tu disais la dc d'erreur de
fignolage ont amené sa salle à tu peux
aucune personne ne sait le temps les
orchidées a régné aux autres leur co
évolution c'est que et vivent dans des
environnements oui des guêpes qui
capturent des araignées les guêpes des
fois capture des araignées les guêpes
solitaire les paralyse les mettre dans
le nid
puis un ippon dieu en disant aux enfants
mais le frigo est plein quand vous
viendrez au monde pouvait manger ça mais
ils font juste les paralyser la pour
qu'ils restent vivants mais assez
horrible mais c'est ça et donc les
orchidées ce qu'ils ont fait les
orchidées à renier ce que y ont pris la
fleur et de sa marine a régné de la
gappe solitaire cherche donc à l'agape
solitaire est en chasse voir la fleur
puis parce que c'est une araignée filet
c'est de l'attrapé et puis je fais
féconder comme ça et en rdc stratégie
comme ça et en a en quantité
industrielle et et c'est tout ça là
comment quand tu le regardes tu n'as pas
le choix comme individu quand tu
t'intéresses en place à de dire on peut
pas saccager ça c'est trop beau pia n'a
pas d'autres planètes ne cherche ni à la
peau l'autre jour a dit quelque chose
qui me quittes qui a résonné dans -
piste
et sur la question de la vie
extraterrestre oui puis moi dans ma tête
est en et l'infinité pratiquement deux
possibilités de planèze louiset les
chances sont bonnes qui avait de la vie
ailleurs c'est sûr qu'après ça tout
amener une distinction peut te dis pour
qu'ils aillent l'humain sa planète terre
c'est une suite de hasards infinie mais
oui de azor complet oui puis d'évolution
des petites afin 0,000001 % de chances
qu'on retrouve ici maintenant
oui je me dis effectivement peut-être
que y'a plus c'est a par ailleurs gelé a
évolué différemment je pense pas que la
vie et rome je pense que la vie
intelligente technologique
c'est ce qui nous permet d'aller dans
l'espace puisque les héros je pense que
c'est extrêmement extrêmement rare sinon
il y en avait partout en tout cas
peut-être cana parce que l'univers est
énorme
moi c'est énorme il ne s'est même pas le
terme mais moi je crois que on a une
belle planète c'est là la 11è qu'elle
existe elle est là la vie quand on
regarde on a calculé si on ramenait
l'histoire de la terre en une journée de
24 heures
l'humain est apparu sur la terre à 23h59
56,5 en parler là nous avons arabe
seconde existence
l'immersion mais si on prend l'histoire
de l'univers en termes d asi l'histoire
de l'univers c'est encore pour beaucoup
aussi
ouais mais quatre saisons d'existence la
paix en 15 secondes tu réussis à bousier
parce que là on en a pas vu de planeur
avec de l'eau liquide c'est l'eau
liquide qui fait qu'on est là c'est
celle autorise une loterie cosmique
hubert reeves 10 à 12 soit c'est une
auto rico smic qui nous a créé vraiment
qu'il va on est tombé entre dans un
étroit couloir du système solaire
compatible avec l'existence d'eau à
l'état liquide
c'est si on était un peu plus loin ça
gèle plus proche à ce rapport et en est
tombée au bon endroit et pour moi en
tout cas comme biologiste qui adore les
sciences de la vie je me dis c'est la
probabilité là c'est pas
c'est en tout cas hors terre la ouais
y'a pas de piscine dans plus de liquide
on n'a pas vu un si j'étais sur une
planète ailleurs et que je je me
développe là comme un autre forme
d'intelligence et que j'apprends que
homo sapiens m'a découvert si je vais
aller me cacher ouais c'est sûr je
sortirai plus jamais parce que tu vois
pas la voir chez toi sûr qu'il va [ __ ]
le bordel et l'histoire a prouvé par
tout ce qui est arrivé il ya détruit
fatah n'ont qu'à le pote tu veux pas
être l'espèce envahi par l homo sapiens
quelqu'un qui avait dès lors qu'on a vu
qu'on voit c'est marc cela ne soyez pas
certains je suis suisse et les martiens
qui pleure en apprenant que l'humain qui
existe c'est stressant c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas les intérêts à 100 d'une
invasion extraterrestre parce qu'on se
projette et wisi on se dit lui michel
fouquet qui est arrivé en amérique ce we
you conquis les taux y arriver si on
détruit mais sont peut-être pas
pacifique d'enfants aux autres c'est
juste que nous le caractère ou le projet
sur les autres intérêts ce qu'on pense
tu vas retrouver sa wii et nous quand on
les regarde c'est juste pour chercher à
une civilisation exploiter quelques
pions souhaité mais à un moment donné
ils vont arriver ici ça va être des
sodomies thater évoluer sur une planète
bonjour toi mêmes rêves d'artois
on me dit rsa parce que bon mais on est
capable du bon quand même 6 7 1 7 6 il
ya quand même encore du oui on a quand
même
cette particularité d'avoir dans le
cerveau des neurones miroirs c'est
qu'ils permettent de voir c'est l'autre
qui en face de toile
ouais tu de didier j'aimerais pas sax à
ce qu'on me fasse ça il ya ça aussi
sauf qu'on réagit souvent trop tard mais
j'avais une autre réflexion par rapport
à notre planète il ya eu beaucoup cm
dans les îles en baisse de seulement
qu'ils voient qu'il faut coloniser mars
parce que notre planète va devoir
détruire puis il faut que la faut que
l'espèce humaine se disperse pour
assurer la survie puis les ressources
que sa demande pour transformer mars en
terre c'est pourquoi on fait juste pour
le transformer la terre à la terre
qu'elle était cynique a pas de
transformer une planète qui coule
complètement hostile à l'humain pour
faire une place pour vivre
on est sûrement capable de prendre la
planète puis de ramener sommes plus
proches de qualité comme à l'epoque
en tout cas on a une belle bleue puis je
veux dire tous les gens qui le regardent
la terre de haut et trouve que simple
c'est un petit joyau si c'est un joyau
improbable c'est puis je pense c'est
surtout sa lancée les efforts de veine
yann dont il parle ça fait pas de
mutation c'est si on mangeait plus de
manger plus végétal imagine
après qu'on ferait une énorme différence
c'est plein plein plein dedans plein
plein de domaines
je suis ont diminué de moitié oui oui la
consommation de viande là ça aurait un
impact tellement énorme c'est ça c'est
quelque chose qui se laisse mais c'est
l'impact environnemental moi je sais pas
un fake
je n'étais pas du tout au courant avant
que ma copine m'en parle
les enjeux environnementaux de tulle oui
les industries pinault est métissée
c'est énorme
puis ce sera moi j'étais pas au courant
là dessus je pense qu'ils m'ont tout le
monde s'intéresse vraiment beaucoup à
l'environnement le oui avec raison sens
la vue les élections européennes qui
viennent de passer la main désolé là
même qui sait pas soupçonner que les
verts vont percer et ça va être pareil
s'il aimait me situe juste l'âme c'est
bien là le sister act ivités c'était
l'enjeu pratiquement sur toutes les
lèvres tous ceux qui s'opposaient à la
caq tous les opposants ce dès lors leur
cheval de bataille platine le cet
incident ainsi d'un nouvel même le
gouvernement de la cacp le choix de
prendre au sérieux parce qu'ils
reviennent au sérieux ils le pren parce
qu'ils savent que je pense que c'est
l'enjeu du siècle des langes et puis les
jeunes générations là moi je le vois
chez mes enfants je le vois chez leurs
amis
c'est cet important pour eux de dire non
vous pouvez pas au nom de vous mois
seulement et moi et toi et booker
conflit inclus dit ben nous autres là ce
qui nous intéresse c'est nous et ceux
qui vont passer après nous il en a rien
à [ __ ] en lice
c'est comme si tu l'industrie du
nucléaire le nucléaire l'industrie on
prend des barriques oms a rempli de
déchets nucléaires ont dit on va les
laisser là là ça va durer deux ans megan
il ya personne qui l'attesté la
principauté ont probablement que dans
pas longtemps ça peut être 50 70 ans n'a
depuis dix ans les gars on sera plus si
ceux qui ont pensé ça il ya des failles
là dedans lancé en tête de toutes sortes
et 1
mais imaginez le bordel dans lequel les
jeunes les générations futures est bon
vraiment avec ça tu es un chaos complet
total plie sont pas responsables ils
étaient même pas là quand ça se faisait
les africains ont proverbe qui dit nous
n'héritons pas de la terre de nos
parents nous empruntons celle de nos
petits-enfants
c'est comme ça qu'on devrait faire c'est
mais malheureusement c'est pas ça c'est
pas s'appuyer
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une belle
façon de voir ce vraiment c'est la
première fois que j'entends c'est
vraiment un site web très parlant comme
comme proverbe
oui mais j'ai plusieurs trous moi j'aime
beaucoup cité celui là où celui des
premières nations d'amérique et à notre
chef qui disait quand l'homme aurait tué
le dernier animal couper le dernier ab
poli et la dernière goutte d'eau il
comprendra enfin que l'argent n'est pas
comestible
ah ben ça c'est bon parce que c'est ça à
quoi ça sert quant à beaucoup d'argent
quand a pas d'air à respirer et vous
voit en chine
merci aux gens si ça reste des débats ou
est-ce que tu rentres puits oui ceci
c'est démesuré et et sa planète terre
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est ici
cependant l'adhb exigeant mais moi je
pense qu'il va falloir remettre en cause
ce culte et cette espèce de d'autres
tirent la croissance économique va tout
en croisant ward croître mais ça marche
pas parce que dans la nature une
croissance continue ça n'existe pas dans
la nature et la nature est là pour nous
servir d'exemple et je veux dire dans le
monde végétal passé sans mettre les
arbres là les problèmes de circulation
commence ça veut dire créer limite un
temps dans la mer le plus gros c'est la
baleine bleue c'est la baleine bleue
elle a de la misère à se référer bas
puis s'il y avait un petit changement
c'est lui qui partirent aisée pas le
petit et perdre
oui il va partir plus vite passé trop
grosse et difficile à déplacer et pour
moi ce sont des indices pour dire aux
gens on ne peut pas croître
continuellement
on ne peut pas quoi sur une est fini
mais sur une planète dont les ressources
sont finies et il sait comment
mathématiquement c'est impossible il
faut avoir le courage de dire il faut
que ça s'arrête il ya vraiment une
tendance actuelle sur la décroissance
mais à nakiele
pour ça je suppose que ça ou au moins qu
on arrête quand qu'on stagne
un blanc tôt ouais voilà la seule chose
c'est que je trouve qu'il souvent dans
ses discours l'on remette on remet
souvent la responsabilité sur
l'individualité fait-on recyclage
consomment moins de ce oui c'est
important
maman dis il faut que plus haut dans les
paliers de baston que soit pris parce
que si si si les taux ou si les
multinationales et autres leurres leur
objectif c'est encore la croissance
quand même qui comme un individu nous
autres c'est le fameux pas difficile qui
a été confirmée on nationale
individuellement on peut décider un on a
un pouvoir de décision c'est quand c'est
ce que les gens disent acheter c'est
voter là mais c'est ça aussi c'est que
pour moi c'était on a notre part une
petite part chacun fait à la mesure de
ses capacités mais on peut faire une
petite part chacun six mois je raconte
souvent la théorie du colibri ici il y
avait un gros feu dans la forêt puis
toutes les animaux courait partout sauf
le colibri qui allaient dans la crainte
des gouttes d'eau puis mettez c'est le
brasier puis on m'a donné le tattoo lui
dit mais rien n'est pas en faire quoi
l'institut a été menée a été goûté 12
puis le colibri répond non je ne sais
pas mais je fais mon devoir c'est ça
c'est ça aussi qu'on devrait faire parce
que c'est des petites choses comme ça
qui font qu'on va avoir un poids à vide
sur sur les décideurs de pouvoir le
diben on sait on va pas la gagne
la cac quand ils sont arrivés au pouvoir
la whey environnement c'était loin
derrière mais ils ont vu bien que de
petit à petit toutes les jeunes se
réunissent 10 mars puis 10 des noms on
n'accepte pas pillay ont décidé que ben
ils sont verts au début j'étais jaune
pâle puis la zone vers c'est pas vert
lime ou je sais pas quoi là mais en tout
cas ils essaient pas qu'on va forer mais
je sens ce voyage
1 une citation passé sur facebook je
pense était de 10 heures on n'a pas
besoin d'une personne sur dix qui zéro
déchet à 100%
on a besoin de 10 personnes sur dix qui
font le mieux de leurs capacités et wii
puis c'est ça qu'il faut dire moi j'aime
beaucoup ça y est c'est parce que si tu
crains que les gens dans les pointant du
doigt puis en le disant vous n'avez pas
c'est la même chose pour le véganisme
c'est exact et les deux extrêmes les
deux extrêmes pour moi ils ont leur part
ils ont ils doivent exister mais s'ils
sont les porte paroles ça marche pas
fait que pour moi c'est ça la ccl juste
de 10 je fais de mon mieux si mes temps
que moi on est une famille on a une
voiture voulait pu en acheter une
deuxième mais on a une voiture c'est ça
on essaie de faire avec ça on essaye de
changer ici si on décide de manger de la
viande mais ont lâché le producteur du
coin et locales c'est bio on peut se
permettre ça donc forfait en a marre il
pas beaucoup mais on a quand il mange
bien on apprend on apprend dans un
endroit spécifique
je comprends aussi que la grande
majorité de la population ne peut pas
faire ça c'est faux pour pas faire c'est
là qu'il faut faire attention de pointer
les gens puis de l'heure de les
culpabiliser pas si tu le fais tu
braques les gens qui on le voit beaucoup
dans les réseaux sociaux ait des gens
quand tu leur parles des climats
changement climatique ils te font un
doigt d'honneur
on le sait nous on écrit l'adoucît il
faut doigt d'honneur parce qu'ils se
sentent invectivé et ils vont te dire ok
moi tu penses tu que je suis capable de
citer un poulet biologique
mais ces deux défaites comme tu dis à
péage essayer de faire du mieux que vous
pouvez du mieux les capacités de tout le
monde quitte et c'est le même principe
si si tout le monde conserve ses
habitudes de consommation le regarder
l'exemple de la viande parce que c'est
quelque chose que je connais bien mais
si tout le monde conserve les mêmes
habitudes de consommation cette façon-là
de s'alimenter est impossible c'est pas
viable que tout le monde puisse manger
la viande d'élevage 100%
frings 100% bio quelle équation
impossible point on manquerait des spas
sont totalement d'accord avec toi fais
ça revient encore à la question de
changer ses habitudes de surconsommation
de 1,2 de croissance constante
mais on peut diminuer c'est que juste
diminué du tiers
exact woods et du capteur consommation
de viande s'allège les jours ceux ci
tout une journée par semaine
oui tu demandes un monde une journée par
semaine et vegan milliards bah oui mais
tu vois ça mais c'est moi je trouve que
c'est bien formulé comme ça ça enlève un
peu le poids sur les épaules de
quelqu'un qui dit mal à moi j'aimerais
ça faire ma part mais je peux prêts à le
faire au complexe al asiri si tout le
monde faisait vegan une fois par semaine
ça fait 1 milliard de wagram sur
l'acteur réponse exacte mais pour de
vrai la c6 tous que ça cette image et
puis une croissance kapisa aux gens qui
n'étaient pas on n'est pas aussi dans le
fait de les culpabiliser parce que c'est
ça le danger dans les discours comme ça
c'est de dire hey tu pourrais laisser
une fois vous mangez ce que ma blonde
hier il dit vous allez manger des
sandwichs notamment personnes qui braque
et contre cette posture le nom une fois
l'important c'est que c'est
c'est vraiment c'est un sujet qui est
qui extrêmement pertinent d'aborder puis
content qu'on avait pu et qu'on peut
qu'on puisse en parler
il sera longtemps un sujet je pense qui
sera jamais de l'autre côté il va rester
là c'est nous a créé un parfum les
humains l'humain n'est pas un animal
parfait puis moi je pense que son
intelligence c'est ça aussi sa faiblesse
ouais trop intelligent il est trop
intelligent et il pense toujours qui est
capable de même 6 mai le bordel il va
être capable de le réparer après c'est
l'intelligence est un couteau à double
tranchant
moi je trouve parce que c'est la seule
chose qui fait qu' il n'est ce pas c'est
assez sur une blague puis en train de
l'acier lui même en même temps oui tu es
la seule espèce qui fait ça l'humain
c'est une rigolade
je me demande comment nous regarde les
autres espèces et les femmes de changer
la perspective
oui des justes les grands singes
l'action très proche de nous et que tu
le diable c'est qu'ils savent qu'en
plein a déjà plongé ton regard dents
longues auryn ne regardant gorrite c'est
ce que lui comprend à écope même quand
il est de l'autre côté dans un hôpital
regarde là tu vois qui sait exactement
ce qui arrive
il le sait mais ce 6e c'est difficile
ils l'exercent à ses traits du château
dassault dans un contexte comme un jour
en allant mais ils savent où ils sont
six et ils les graphes et ils le savent
qu'ils regardent dans les yeux puis
aujourd'hui on le sait l'unicité de
l'espèce humaine s'était mis lui-même
pays fait partie d'une base plus large
seul animal regarde tout ce qu'on
pensait qu'il ya juste l'humain qu'il
fait fabriquer des outils tout ça des
chimpanzés font ça ils fabriquent des
outils et les chimpanzés il mémorise
c'est pas comme les pilleurs il enseigne
aux jeunes sera fabriquée l'outil les
chimpanzés font de la politique
si tu lis sur les chimpanzés quand ils
sont en campagne électorale tu verras
que les humains n'ont rien n'est vrai
les chimpanzés ont des deux campagnes
électorales où les mâles font des
alliances entre europe
les vieux mâles qui ont perdu le pouvoir
tire les ficelles en arrière comme au
parti québécois
le syndrome du parti écoute et ils vont
les mâles s'en vont voir les formules
comme dans les campagnes électorales
essayé d'appuyer les formes elle partage
et de la viande avec les x men pour
s'assurer le vote des femmes on a même
vu des prétendants au trône prendre les
bébés pour essayer de faire d'attirer la
sympathie quatre exactement comme fond
d'une prostituée demain il faut tout et
quand tu regardes ça tu sais que on n'a
rien inventé si on est juste
l'aboutissement de quelque chose qui
existait avant nous les chimpanzés ont
le sens de l'humour ne voient ils font
rire il faut des gags et rigolent et il
se basait qui s'offraient fait beaucoup
parler j'aime ces facteurs le raconte ça
dans un livre qui s'appelle le bonobo
dieu et nous et le ce1 pas et un dessin
pas et mettait de l'eau dans ses joues
puis attendait les enfants qu'ils
savaient qu'ils vont lui faire fi des
canons qui ouvrait la bouche il faut se
lever il a toutes les autres faisait
rigoler dit c'est pas mais tout ce qu'on
pensait que c'est spécifique à l'humain
ne l'est pas l'adoption de la
réconciliation a mené les deux mâles qui
se dispute à se réconcilier pias a
enterré la hache de guerre tout ça ils
font ça les bonobos font ça les cours y
si tu vois que on est pas on n'est pas
comme on est la une est l'aboutissement
de quelque chose du style qui peut être
qu'il nous regarde puis nous analyse
depuis dix ans ils vous elle sait pas
quoi faire avec et on peut compris
quelque chose hein
il ya même un documentaire sur une femme
qui prenait le langage des signes ou je
pense que je me suis identifié et
tissent et les spécialistes qui avait
vraiment le chimpanzé est capable de
communiquer le dic a pas de réelle envie
de quad est capable de 2 6 0
il y avait tout appris le thé capable de
formuler des phrases je me rappelle plus
le chiffre exact mais c'est au dessus de
90 % de nos jeunes y sont les morts
cette taverne % qu'on partage avec mes
chiens canadiana juste 1% qui nous
différencie ce qu'on est
est ce qu'on pense qu'on est supérieurs
différents cet hiver on est différent
les chimpanzés font des résolutions de
choses là que l'humain ne pourra jamais
cessé exams et maurice des chiffres et
ils tuent leur donne douze chiffres on a
vu des expériences faites par des
japonais là il mémorise l'emplacement
des chiffres qui tout et tu les fais
disparaître
ils le font dans l'ordre suite l'humain
au camp du minck est capable de faire ça
si c'est des animaux ils ont développé
une intelligence qui est propre à
laurence ferrand et nous on a développé
une intelligence différents mais il
reste qu ils sont très proches de nous
un sacrifice france soir là une bonne
définition est dit lui-même c'est un
animal qui hantent les chimpanzés les
bonobos c'est vous connaissez les
bonobos le bonobo c'est le singe qu'on a
toujours su qu'on bosse la réussite du
fleuve congo est celle des singes qui
règle tous pas le cul la lettre
dès qu'il ya une tension il faut que ça
finit là en continu qui rencontre une
autre famille de bonobo la tension
s'installe les faux mails hadopi dit ok
les gars en organisant partout depuis la
paix revienne
y a pas de bagarres son fils faut régler
la guerre par l'amour laisse à
l'ajustement est donc les bonobos c'est
les singes les plus peaceful des grands
singes jamais de bagarre et c'est les
femelles qui ont le pouvoir
les faux mails ont pris le pouvoir chez
les bonobos repos et chez les chimpanzés
les mâles qui ont le pouvoir et les
miliciens pas et c'est la guerre c'est
le pouvoir s'est passée la violence et
l'intimidation
ils ont des réconciliations c'est
l'intimidation des femelles et françois
lady b l'humain c'est les deux cousins
il est au milieu
il a le potentiel des deux c'est à dire
que le bonobo vouloir régler tout par le
qi est encore chez lui qu'on appelle le
bon vieux niqab c'est l'avis des années
ils ont essayé le bonobo lewis la
technique bonnabaud gérer disant voilà
c'est les malades du sida série continue
et les maladies qui le rend si c'est pas
une bonne idée d'aller ramener au centre
mais pas de trop à gauche à droite vous
pouvez pas régler tous vos problèmes par
le cul imagine un si cette fois qu'il ya
opposition au coup cela vous inspire
monsieur le président un de ces caméras
qui sont revenus en sorte mais ils ont
le pool le potentiel du chimpanzé aussi
la violence et l'intimidation la
jalousie td fois parce que le voisin à
regarder ta blonde tu vas y sauter
dessus et ça c'est les lois qui ont dit
non non non pouvais pas attaquer l'autre
juste parce qu'à regarder ta blonde
revient au centre et l'humain entre les
deux et u10 et lui dit lui même laissé
les chimpanzés et règle les problèmes de
pouvoir par le sexe et les bonobos les
bonobos régler pour les problèmes de
pouvoir par le sexe et les chimpanzés
règle les problèmes de sexe pendant le
poids c'est moi le plus fort si je me
sers le premier puis j'en vois une et
tulle et voire même les mâles
subalternes s'aiment pas et on en voit
là une normale en érection puis voit le
mâle dominant arrivée pipi-caca bizoune
c'est pour qu'il me voit pas ce que
c'est par magie tout est dit
c'est fou c'est vrai que chez lui mais
on est comme les petits des plus petits
démons en même temps la note est qui qui
qui qui joue qui tire puis est justement
là dans son livre une formule que j'ai
vraiment aimé que je pense qu'un
proverbe sénégalais qui on a du lourd
c'est à ça c'est plus un cd cherokee
wiggins est un conte qui vient d'être
évoqué on ne le l'outil de qui rempli de
haine de jalousie de violence pour le
loup de la bonté puis le vrai de la
générosité puisse laquelle l'udc veut
gagner si c'est lui qui nourrit ses
superbes roddick qui nourrit gagne et on
s'en serait ce comme que l'humain est
capable demain capables du pire au
meilleur
dix ans nous on aura fait on est
constamment des pensées négatives qui
arrive qu'ils connaissaient
l'acquis pitre il ya cette espèce de
combat les all this way entre les deux
qui concernent était moins nombriliste
moi je pense que tout marchera c'est
qu'on est trop s'intéresser nous on
s'inscrit pas on refuse de s'inscrire
dans une nature dont on fait entièrement
partie c est juste qu on est tous tout
ce qu'on pense on repense à fonction de
nous quand on dit une espèce
ça c'est une espèce indésirables ou une
mauvaise herbe et les africains disent
une mauvaise herbe c'est juste une
plante dont vous ne connaissez pas
encore les vertus et ça n'existe pas une
mauvaise herbe de pissenlit ce pas une
mauvaise herbe ça n'existe pas puis donc
vous c'est tout ce qui fait que nous en
observons rapporte nous l'espèce
d'égocentrisme il y en a qui l'appelle
l'anthropocentrisme on s'entend tous nos
besoins à nous mais en même temps ça
peut pas marcher c'est t il faut qu'on
qu'on puisse dire on a des frères des
cousins dans le monde animal et ils sont
là à côté de nous mêmes les bactéries
c'est donc nous assistons non seulement
on disant parler de l'adn des jeunes
qu'on partage avec les chimpanzés mon
partagent le même grand pat notre adn
avec tout ce qui vit ce qui existe on
aime les bactéries on est passé du mince
et une la collaboration en fait il faut
juste tendre la main c'est ça parce que
même lui même d'une société d'élus mais
là c'est pas toi t'es pas un individu
qui est une société au complet il ya
plein et pour chaque cellule de ton
corps à au moins dix cellules
bactériennes donc cet été une société
action là les bactéries seraient
majoritaires et rive en toi et ils sont
responsables de plein de choses que tu
peux pas imaginer
tu as 10 et sciences et des bactéries
font une bonne partie de la digestion si
on a levé tôt microbiote d'humour et
dans pas longtemps
tc il ya tout ça c'est un grand réseau
de reconnaissance et de gratitude michel
lavit et quand on s'inscrit maintenant
il faut dire on doit des mercis à plein
de gens et les bactéries qui sont rendus
à ces des bactéries à un chapitre entier
d'amour dans le bouquin j'ai consacré à
ma mère où je parle de l'héritage
bactérien que nos mamans donnent
picardie vient au monde
mais avant même de venir au monde
les derniers jours de grossesse à une
catégorie de bactéries du microbiote qui
se multiplient dans les voies génitales
de la maman abondamment pour t'apprendre
en disant on va aller en ce moment c'est
le petit quand il va passer rentrer dans
ses narines partout et on va
l'accompagner dans son voyage terrestre
c est ça c'est pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup
de médecins qui disent l'accouchement
par césarienne va bien maintenant elle a
beaucoup qu'ils font plus qu'ils disent
c'est un rendez vous manqué avec tes
amis tu court circuiter amis qui
t'attendait mais quand tu sors même
quand il sort du ventre de ta maman qui
doit pas juste dire merci à la maman et
la génétique mais aux bactéries qui est
allégué et les bactéries passe par le
système immunitaire et rome dans le sein
dans les airs à sorte de lait à des
bactéries là-dedans 1 1
ces bactéries on roule c'est que la
maman être fourni des oubliés pour
digérer le lait en attendant que tu es
en hymne digestive fonctionne tu vois
donc il ya tout ça et tout ces bactéries
ils sont responsables de plein de choses
hsitoire play plein fouet la digestion
les bactéries et dictons système
immunitaire à reconnaître les microbes
il fabrique des vitamines
ils font plein plein d'affaires que tu
peux même pas imaginer un humain quand
on a commencé le projet du génome humain
les biologistes disait on doit avoir 120
100000 j'aime parce qu'on est une espèce
très rare
pire on s'est rendu compte après à la
fin du projet qu'on avait quelque chose
comme 22000 j'aime même le riz à plus de
j'aime qu'un humain et les gens ont
capoté andy murray ans à ce propos un
espinous la puce d'eau à puce et j'aime
que nous mais c'est sans oublier qu'on
avait on pouvait compter si des millions
de gènes bactéries ses soeurs qui sont
des sous traitants et des collaborateurs
qui font partie intégrante de nous qui
fabrique plein de choses pour nous 1
et donc c'est ça c'est faut dire aux
jeunes que la réalité on s'inscrit dans
un tout et ce tous là on ne peut pas se
soustraire de ça et voir juste notre nom
brille ça marche pas on veut pas existé
à l'extérieur ne se plaint pas du tout
pas du tout et les bactéries sont ils à
l'autre théorie mois que j'aime bien
citer c'est l'humain c'est un animal
domestiqué par les bactéries pour voyage
je ne sais pas pour amener nos
bâtisseurs victoire il ya ainsi il a été
domestiqué par le chat on en parlait il
ya été domestiqués par les plantes mais
par les bactéries celle des bactéries c1
j'ai entendu un scientifique britannique
dire face et il a été domestiqué par les
bactéries pour voyager et qui a été le
meilleur véhicule pour les bactéries de
sa pièce
il a décimé des endroits et or est
fidèle au cid et des civilisations louis
par les bactéries
ouais mêmes qui nous manipulent même je
suis sûr que le french kiss et les
bactéries qui l'a inventé juste pour
dire vous voulez partager des bactéries
écoute à la mêlée à mettre la bouche
dans leur bouche idéale exactement ses
meilleurs moyens aux milliards et le
premier baiser c'est un milliard d'entre
nous qui sont allés vélo de beauregard
on applaudit finances c'est ça revient à
tout le monde tout ce qui vit cet
instinct de survie il est à sa place à
sa place et relier tout est relié et
c'est pas parce que on vois pas le lien
qui existe pas
ça veut dire que tu peux enlever un
petit morceau du casse tête et tu vois
tout péricliter sais c'est un peu un
château de cartes mais oui c'est un
château de cartes
1 c'est un château de cartes c'est la
vérité un décès tout est relié quelque
part c puis on ne peut pas juste penser
à nous
moi moi - la compétition la compétition
est un peu pour ça moi qui suis
quelqu'un qui adore beaucoup la théorie
de darwin et je trouve que c'est ils y
ont beaucoup insisté c'est la
compétition qui fait que les gens sont
devenus des mais la vérité c'est que la
vie c'est aussi la collaboration la
compétition existe c'est vrai qu'a fait
partie de la vie mais elle a toujours
côtoyé la solidarité la collaboration en
son nom on se tient la main les plans
sur le modèle à copier les plantes ne
bougent pas ils ont tous les plaines
collaborateurs et ils sont faire les
plantes à fleurs avec les insectes
pollinisateurs
ils ont inventé les fruits aussi pour
les rongeurs en dix ans
il va ouvrir ma caboche mais je vais
t'en donner un peu sauf que je veux
aller c'est une migraine gouailleuse tu
me prends là j'étais mis une couche la
dame en hiver oui ça m'agace maghreb
j'ai récemment d'agrément euros mais
c'est vrai qu'ils sont fantastiques
regarde la france perd la fraise tant
qu'elle n'est pas mûr et les toxiques
riz et pâtes pourra manger une fraise
d'air france est dégueulasse ça contient
des tanins astringence pas bon mais à
partir du moment où les graines sont
prêtes la fraise et devient rouge de
sucre c'est ça pour dire à ses
collaborateurs mais les gars le cadeau
il a même fait votre job a mené les
graines de l'eau bord mais tous les
fruits c'est juste ça et les rongeurs se
sont adaptés aux fruits avec l'évolution
les planteurs inventé plein de choses
pour récompenser ceux qui les disent
émus
c'est une demande le fluide la chair de
la mangue
il sait pas si nécessaire mais à damang
non parce que la crème aidant à
l'intérieur pour protéger et protéger la
grèce une crème comme disait un
biologiste c'est juste un bébé avec un
lunch cia son lunch avec lui tire
lankais dans l'entamé autour on rajoute
quelque chose pour récompenser celui qui
va le transporter un prix qui va aider
je remercie celui qui va aider mon petit
a germé ailleurs c'est la mangue c'est
la pomme 1 hr de pommes et plein de
fruits tout ça c'est des réseaux de
solidarité de gratitude mutuelle je vous
donne ça vous prenez ça mais quand tu
regardes les plans les racines c'est
encore extraordinaire c'est un réseau de
partage fantastique
les racines des plantes ton relier la
grande majorité à des champignons qu'on
appelle les mycorhizes les mycorhizes
colonisent les racines et ceux des
sous-traitants des âmes
ils vont chercher les sels minéraux vont
chercher l'eau ils vont envoyer ça à la
plante la plante monde sans eau fabrique
des sucs et les récompenses en bas le
renvoi jusqu'à 30% de ceux qui
fabriquent à ses collaborateurs en bas
et les mycorhizes ils font de la sous
traitance avec des bactéries qui vont
les aider à protéger la plante des
maladies c'est ça la vie aussi c'est pas
juste la compétition
l'humain c'est ça aussi c'est un réseau
de gratitude notre poser des bactéries
qu'ils aient pris la protègent et qui
luttent contre plein plein plein de
bactéries indésirables qu'ils veulent
nous faire du mal et les enlève c'est
quand tu vas dans notre bouche c'est
pareil tu devras dans nos intestins et à
des bactéries t'appelais de micro
organismes qui nous aident à digérer à
et qui nous aide même à se reproduire
parce que c'est démontrer que la laine
de l'individu six cas quelqu'un tu
rencontre quelqu'un c'est d'abord
l'odeur de la personne qui attire
beaucoup de gens mais le loader ont
lancé les bactéries qui sont en nous qui
sont en grande partie responsables de
l'odeur qu'on dégage ça veut dire que
même dans notre production sont là j'en
prends d'en avoir notre attirance de
même dans notre attirance mutuelle sont
la télésérie par les bactéries de
l'autre personne bain à partie parce que
l'odeur a fait partie si quand tu
embrasses la personne qui partage avec
des bactéries
ça c'est le spermatozoïde et trois
partitas là que la pièce intermédiaire
la tête et le chapeau qui ce qu'on
appelle la cre aux hommes mais les
évolutionnistes ça que la pièce
intermédiaire la partie brune ici nous
vient des bactéries s'y voit qu'ils ont
même investi dans notre production parce
que ce sont la pièce intermédiaire est
rempli de deux micros de deux heures
d'organites qu'on appelle les
mitochondries les mitochondries ce sont
les centrales énergétiques des cellules
qui permet de lisser et les centrales
logistiques qui font battre là que le
moteur est ici les spermatozoïdes mais
le moteur
les mitochondries ce sont d'anciennes
bactéries qui sont entrés à nous mais
qui sert à faire avancer les
spermatozoïdes tu vas quand même dans
notre production ils sont là l'énergie
avec laquelle les spermatozoïdes avance
vers l'ovule
ce sont d'anciens battre
ricky nous la fournissons nous tu vois
ce que je dis ok alors c'est ça veut
dire que quelque part ils sont là à
toutes les étapes toutes les étapes de
la vie
ben ils sont là parce qu'ils étaient là
avant nous n'est ce pas
l'évolution du vivant doit aux bactéries
et depuis plus de 3.5 milliards d'années
y sont là et chaque fois qu'un animal ou
un végétal à manquer de compétences
il a ouvert la main et a tendu la main à
des bactéries qui avait cette compétence
là parce qu'ils font toutes sont
qualifiés dans tout il ya une bactérie
des atouts mais un ph acide le prêt à
céder à une bactérie qui survit là
dedans mais la température la plus
chaude dans les sources thermales il ya
une tante bactéries qu'il fait fabriquer
une vitamine il ya une bactérie qui est
capable de le faire fabriquer d'horreur
même les bactéries sont capables de
fabriquer de l'or et puis dit n'importe
quoi
s'ils cherchent ils ont eu des
compétences sont diversifiés et c'est
avec eux que ça a commencé
c'est donc ils sont à toutes les étapes
ils y ont vu tout ça se produit et ils
sont partout partout une vache c'est
juste un gros mammifères qui qui se fait
entretenir par des micro-organismes ils
mangent de l'herbe l'herbe ya rien là
dedans mais la vache il s'est développé
deux estomac hainard désistement pour
kiki kick dans lequel se trouve plein de
micro organismes qui font la vache en
fait c'est ça et tous les animaux ils
sont partout mais on passe quand on
gouverne la planète mais c'est les
bactéries gouverner c'est sûr oui c'est
ça c'est sûrement la vision qu'on a
clear l'être humain de sa propre place
dans tout ce système
ben moi en tout cas au moins ça dit aux
gens bien il faut se replacer au centre
de sa et arrêter de voir l'unicité de
l'espèce humaine pickeu dont nous sommes
les seuls puis les plus importants de
l'univers ça n'existe pas si c'est pas
se dit lui même c'est les religions
monothéistes ont beaucoup compté
yasar en disant que dieu a créé puis il
pour que tout le reste soit ont servi
les premiers à la jeunesse qui est écrit
voilà mais on devrait y rajouter aussi
kate a créé aussi pour que tu sois
conscient que tous et tout ça là c'est
important c'est pas parce que tu es plus
intelligent que tu dois tout détruire ça
c'est important de s'occuper de ses
réseaux 2g dit souvent mais c'est un
réseau de gratitude mais mutuelle
personne ne s'est réalisée tout seul en
existe vraiment le self made man tu
crois pas et je trouve que c'est une
belle conclusion affectation exact merci
énormément hésité avec nous j'ai jamais
parlé de biologie aussi longtemps jamais
dans aucun endroit dans ma visite
on est extrêmement flatté d'avoir été
versées sur le but de podcasts aussi
c'est de pouvoir approfondir des ces
sujets-là d'en parler puis ça intéresse
beaucoup plus les gens qu'on pense je
priais finances yves ça intéresse les
gens je serai le podcast avec toi
aujourd'hui les gens vont l'adorer
c'est sûr que ça va passer pas
l'histoire mais ça va un autre que dix
mois les gens qui nous suivent ça il
sait que la merci à vous merci à finir
ce cas
[Musique]